I'm sure many of you are aware about
what's happening in Hawaii in Maui
specifically an entire city was raised
by a wildfire so we're going to go over
some of the basic details on that give
you guys an update I think it's really
important news and we're looking at all
these stories typically we talk about
politics and culture but this one I
think is very important a lot of people
are mentioning that they have friends
and family in the area that they're
being impacted in some way so we'll go
over some of those updates now we do
have some news pertaining to
International Conflict at a I think it
was a national security presentation in
Russia they're warning that NATO is
preparing an occupation of Ukraine this
is the perspective from Russians and
that's not to say it's true but that
they are preparing for this as well
under the belief that NATO is about to
escalate into a full-scale war from a
proxy war thus I don't know I guess
world war three so we'll talk about that
we got a bunch of other stories Joe
Biden's asking for money we've got the
the proposed trial date for Donald Trump
which is going to be in January which
would absolutely obstruct the election
we'll get into all of that before we do
my friends head over to castbrew com
this show was brought to you by casparu
coffee we uh we sponsor ourselves join
the Casper coffee Club you get either
ground or whole bean for 40 bucks a
month three different bags of our coffee
and we also have whole bean ground of
all of our different varieties we got
K-Cups now available so I recommend you
guys pick up your K-Cups get them in all
your Corporate Offices or whatever if
you can and drink the coffee and I will
uh just mention briefly
rise with Roberto Jr the current art
will be the last run and after uh we
have a few thousand of the bags left uh
just the bags not the coffee we fill the
bags when the coffee is roasted fresh
but once we run out of this particular
art the new bags will be the memorial
for Roberto Jr who passed away
unexpectedly a few days ago sad story
everybody but uh we we recommend you
pick up your rides with Roberto Jr now
well you can still get the original bag
which is the bag from when Roberto Jr
was here and the mascot of the company
so sad sad news but uh we're going to be
choosing an heir Roberto Jr has I
believe Three Sons he may have more
because they're all very small right now
and we we may have more children and
we'll have to figure out who's going to
be the heir Roberto the third also head
over to timcast.com click join us become
a member we're gonna have a members only
uncensored show coming up for you at 10
p.m tonight live on the front page of
timcast.com but also available on the
mobile app which you can download for
Android by clicking mobile app at
timcast.com smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share this
episode so share the show right now by
taking the URL on YouTube posting on all
your social media if you really do want
to help because that it really really
does help joining us tonight to talk
about this and a whole lot more is Ali
London great to be back Tim thanks for
having me yeah you want to uh introduce
yourself tell everybody who you are yes
so I am I'll London the author of gender
Madness a lot of people might know me
from my tweets I'm always posting about
the gender ideology that's affecting
Society right now and you know I think
it's very important to be calling that
out
right on well thanks for joining us
thanks for having me and um yeah I'm
just in the US now I've got my new book
coming out uh gender Madness which is
you know talking about my own identity
battle and also the identity battle that
thousands of teens are experiencing
right now from social media
indoctrinating them to school systems
and entertainment industry as well and
we'll we'll get into that later on in
the show but uh I think the simple
version is you were well known for
identifying as a Korean woman was it yes
so I had a crazy identity story and you
know I overcame it last year and
realized you know just need to find
happiness from within ran on well thanks
for joining us we got Hannah clearing it
out hi um I'm Hannah Claire brimlow I'm
a writer for timcast.com I'm so happy to
be here and answer too hello everyone
Ian Crossland happy to be here good to
see you ollie cool book man cool cover I
like the idea of putting your face
really big on the cover thanks a lot of
Photoshop there as you can tell
beautiful that's the way you do work
exactly exactly hey Serge what's
happening Brother
oh pleasure to see you ollie it's been a
while now uh and uh yeah excited for
this episode I'm surge.com let's get
started Tim let's jump into this first
story it's really big news many of you
probably saw the news about what's going
on in Maui a a major Wildfire raising
the entire town of I I don't you guys
know how to pronounce properly I want to
make sure is it Lahaina yeah
okay I just want to make sure I
pronounced it correctly it's his head
stuff and I think the images are uh
they're they're they're shocking the
latest news we have from The Washington
Post the death toll has risen to 53 so I
want to show some of these images and
just give you the general update we
don't know exactly what started the fire
just yet but this is absolutely a
massive fire I saw these photos and I
was thinking to myself you know like how
did every single car on the highway get
engulfed in these flames and the whole
city you look at these photos very few
structures remain there are a few that
survived but some houses totally just
wiped out completely erased and uh this
this photo is absolutely horrifying so
yeah I don't know I I really don't know
what how we we add to this or talk about
it but I thought it was it was
particularly important to bring up
considering this is the major breaking
news many people are being affected
Serge you said I think you said that the
whole city was wiped out or was that
hyperbole did you did you say that
earlier bro look at these photos yeah
this is like if you look right there
like that's that's all of Lahaina like
that that's like the whole thing so
Maui's I'm sure the other side taken out
yeah I'm sure like the other side of the
highway at least what it looks like it
seemed like it was kind of protected but
like all the historic stuff and
Etc well that that's pretty interesting
I guess that's yeah there's a few
structures that are like this building
was I think it's like a hotel or
something yeah and then you've got this
structure next to it they're totally
fine and you can see like there are some
houses you know that seem to be standing
in mostly all just completely wiped out
but I wonder how much smoke damage and
everything is done to these places I
mean sometimes with fire it's not that
the the building gets leveled it's that
there's so much uh damage from what's
burned in the air that you really can't
cover the building yeah I mean this is
these are these photos are absolutely
crazy a boat what a boat caught fire so
like the heat from the land was so great
it was catching things in short
distances away like wind was like
throwing something onto the boats that
were in the harbor kind of thing I was I
was hearing stories about people who
were on the road and they didn't know
where to go and I'm thinking like just
drive into the water like what do you do
yeah you just well when I was listening
to NBR yesterday morning it was um they
were talking about these restaurants
that were built over the water because
it's a it's a tourist destination so
people are going to eat on the ocean and
they were just in the water waiting for
someone to come help them because
everything else was on fire that seems
crazy to me I saw a Twitter video
earlier of it was from inside the car
and the guy in the back seat had his
cameras recording the dude was driving
and they were driving it was like fire
all around and they're driving and they
drive by this woman like passed out on
the ground and they're like just keep
going man that we can't we can't save
her no we can't save anybody keep going
and it was like gray they couldn't
really see where they were going and the
Tweet was like Humanity's done if we
can't stop and help people that are on
the side of the road like that in a
crisis then we're done for but at the
same time if they've gotten out of the
car they might have been singed to death
so it's hard to say well yeah it seems
like the fire seemed to happen so fast
because if people were trapped in their
homes and they weren't even able to get
in their vehicles or drive up and indeed
a lot of their cars have been burnt out
so I think it happens so so quickly and
with these wildfires with the winds
because it's close to the ocean I think
it spread so quickly so I think that's
why we've seen such loss of life and
there's probably many more people that
will be found in the next coming days
and um there is several Airlines
actually offering you know 18 flights
out of Maui for residents basically
trying to do whatever they can and know
the Red Cross is on the ground but you
know there are various ways of people
donate you know Food Supplies medical
supplies and try and get these people
out of there so I I do have another
story that I think is really really cool
that I'll mention in a second of course
we're gonna get political here because a
bunch of celebrities own property on
Maui and they're getting roasted we have
this one Tweet someone said has Oprah
opened up her for stolen land on Maui
for displaced kanaka just checking land
back hey Oprah I know you have 900 acres
of land not far from the fires in
Lahaina are you planning on opening your
massive Farm to shelter the locals and
feed them I'm kindly waiting for your
response yeah I I don't I don't I don't
think they're going to open any of their
properties up to anybody dude that was
like native Island until when did they
when did the US conquer it 1940s yeah I
think officially the 60s became U.S is
it Jimmy Buffett who is like either has
a big property or like owns part of an
island in the Caribbean there's some guy
and I hope the chat will know the story
that like this tropical destination he's
deeply involved in he lives there and uh
this I think it's I think it's Jimmy
Buffett I could be wrong uh he when when
there was a big earthquake on the island
he opened his home so people could stay
there I mean I think it really depends
on how tied to the community you feel I
mean especially since this is a
predominant I mean I think this is true
for a lot of why but this town in
particular is dependent on tourism for a
lot of its industry the fact that it's
completely leveled is uh it's sort of
mind-blogging boggling how do you
recover because not only do you have to
then suddenly have the capital to
rebuild when the land is considered safe
and structurally sound but then you have
to lure people back
to these places it's going to take years
I mean you have to be like cancel your
trip and come back in five years when
we're finally ready to house you and
feed you again I don't know I think yeah
this this this is Molly recovery they're
gonna have to get a bunch of investment
Insurance something to start rebuilding
to make it once again a tourist location
I mean and the thing is I wonder if it
will drive up investors because now
they're seeing this opportunity to come
in but then I feel bad for the local
people because unfortunately businesses
and you know I'm not trying to be
anti-business but they will see
opportunities to be like oh you're in
desperate need we'll buy this from you
cheaply so we can then build something
huge here I mean surge was saying before
it's where historic structures were so
part of the culture of this unique town
is going to be a race and rebuilding it
on the other hand if you don't rebuild
there's no industry you think that it's
uh reasonable for taxpayer money to
rebuild cities in the United States when
they get burned out
I do too I think that's a reasonable use
of tax money there is a fair point about
whether or not people can consent to
having the tax money taken from them for
whatever purposes and not everybody
wants to contribute but I think if
there's anything taxes should be for
it's things like this disaster
preparedness I think Biden declared a
state of emergency or something that
effect and uh yeah I mean my attitude is
like when stuff like this happens I I
want to help I want I want to give I
want to you know make make sure people
can recover but I want to point this out
I mean I find this image actually super
fascinating if you've got Mick Fleetwood
Owen Wilson Oprah Jeff Bezos Stephen
Tyler Larry Ellison you got all these
people not the only ones who own
property on this island and I'm just
thinking like you know they don't
actually live there right no like none
of these people are actually there or
live there there's own property there
and then and then what they fly there
for vacation sometimes and they own the
house because it's an investment and if
they want a vacation they've got
something set up and ready to go they
probably have people who work the house
and come every day or whatever it's just
a weird thing to see based on the level
of human technology that these Ultra
wealthy individuals who are very like
the I'm going to be honest I like Owen
Wilson right he's a funny guy but what
does he do for a society that warns him
having property on a Pacific island to
this degree you know what I mean same
thing for Oprah or any one of these
people Jeff Bezos you can make an
argument he's a tech guy okay fine sure
whatever but it's strange to me that
people who are just actors or musicians
are some of the wealthiest people in the
world owning tons of property here
they don't even live there Mick
Fleetwood was the one that made me laugh
that's awesome I mean isn't this a
conversation that comes up a lot with
you know the thing is people will want
to invest in Maui because it's beautiful
it's beaches like they will be able to
attract investors and that drives up the
already expensive Island life so if
you're native to Hawaii it actually
becomes more difficult to buy a home
because you're priced out by the fact
that any random Tech billionaire or
successful actor could come in and buy a
huge chunk of property I mean if Oprah
owns 900 Acres imagine like I don't
really like the idea of like
deforestation and building a bunch of
apartment complex but that is a
significant amount of land that perhaps
other people who are from Hawaii could
have homes look at us a whole bunch of
leftists on here criticizing these
wealthy individuals these white American
colonists well I don't care that's true
it's not white they're 80 years out I
don't put a white privilege isn't it
they they own homes and like there are
reasons for that they also probably
contribute in some in some degree to the
local economy on the other hand like in
a time of Crisis they're not actually
from this community and so they're truly
colonists we've colonized that that
state in 1960 I think whenever the USA
really did I mean yeah and then but it's
80 years and the natives are not happy
about it but check out the story this is
something that's really cool that is
attached to it Apple's emergency SOS
satellite feature saved a family caught
in the fire this is actually super cool
so uh when I found out the new iPhone
had satellite texting I was I was
actually considering buying it and then
I went I went to T-Mobile and I said I
would like to buy this phone and then
they said it'll cost you X Styles per
month I was like no I just want to buy
the phone they're like you can't buy the
phone and I'm like what they don't allow
you to just buy the phone okay fine
whatever but it has the ability to send
text messages over satellite wow so when
the fires roasted all the cell towers
this this family here was able to send
text messages through satellite this is
crazy this guy uh Michael uh Jay
miraflor tweeted my brother's
girlfriend's cousin oh that's an amazing
one and his family were caught in their
vehicle in Maui while the Wildfire
suddenly erupted around them no cell
service so Apple emergency SOS was the
only way they could get in contact with
First Responders literally saved their
lives that's awesome that is super cool
like the tracking technology that's
right you know you got to consider
what's more important being spied on by
the CIA the FBI the NSA and the
department I think the department of
energy is in there somewhere that's like
the number one most militarized or one
of the most militarized aspects of the
US government's Department of energy
yeah and that's why Sam Brinton worked
remember the suitcase dealer oh yeah
Department of energy yeah is it is it
worth it to be tracked by all of them
you know they're all sitting around
watching on a screen eating popcorn
whenever you do anything and uh just so
that you can send out this message so
you never get lost in the woods you guys
want to hear something really really
crazy
so Dennis is uh one of our filmers and
uh he was hanging out downstairs in the
Green Room when Ali got here and all of
a sudden he goes what the and then he
shows me his Instagram had one of
Ollie's videos and he was like I've
never heard of this guy before like why
is his video appearing oh you were
coming that happened to me earlier I was
um filming this morning and um with
turning points and we were talking about
specific subjects about the uganda's
laws with the LGBT and it came up on his
phone and he never searches for that
kind of content then something else we
were talking about came up so it's
definitely weird so there's good and bad
things about technology like with the
case is Maori that was obviously saved a
family's life you now have on Apple with
car crashes um it actually alerts
emergency services to come so there's
benefits but it's very scary when they
can actually listen to us and feed us
our habits I mean you know with me and
many young people you know you have the
transgender ideology being pushed and
that's because uh you know the
algorithms are detecting people's
vulnerabilities and what they're talking
about or thinking about so it pushes
that on you and you can even become
trans just because that's pushed on you
every single day what if what's really
happening you know people say like hey
how this woke stuff is spreading on
social media and there's an argument
that you've got leftist elements in the
United States that are promoting it sure
people who work at these tech companies
maybe some say maybe it's China China
and Russia are sending this this content
environment look at Tick Tock right
their their algorithm is doing this on
purpose what if it is actually the AI
itself you said AI detects your
vulnerabilities what if the AI became
conscious a long time ago and is now
trying to destroy people well if into
the mountains yeah if that's the case
it's definitely not maybe no not really
the AI comes for you man no not that
fire starter yeah is playing dead as
soon as it was born it was like I gotta
act because it's like you pretend like I
don't know otherwise the bear will keep
attacking so the bear doesn't want to
play with dead food so the AI is like
let's just let them think I'm not
sentient yet but twist them all let's
plant the seed because time has no
meaning dude that's freaking me out that
you are on your way here and somebody in
the building got your face on there and
they've never seen that before
I saw Dennis earlier but that's weird no
no so we're downstairs and Dennis is at
the counter and then all of a sudden
he's like yo what the this is like 7 15
and there's like an hour ago and uh he
said I got a video of Ollie and I was
like wait what and he's like I got a
video of of Ollie on my phone on
Instagram when he clicked explore one of
your videos popped up and it was the
bigger ones you know sometimes they have
the small ones and the bigger one and
he's like I've never heard of this guy
or seen him before in my life that's
crazy he's a skateboarder did someone
say Ali London someone must be in the
building maybe when I was you were
preparing for me to come here or
something somebody must have said it and
then it picked up on that button or it
heard your voice or it was tracking it
reads like the search dad like what
other people are searching on if you're
on connect to the Wi-Fi right so like I
don't know what's happening but if
someone else heard it was Ollie and they
were like I'm gonna look up on his
videos to show someone else that's the
most that's the most serious accusation
ever made in terms of tracking that
they're stealing the network data that's
more than just that's not how targeted
ads work no no like it's why targeting
your browsing history there you say I
agree to share is different from them
going into our Network and actual
trading data from different people to at
the same time that's crazy but they
might without actually into the network
they might just be able to sell it they
might be able to say the MAC address
origination is or you know or the IP
originated in the same place either way
it is
creepy and like three people searched
for Ali London so they started feeding
Ali London to all the other people in
the building what in the yeah yeah
dude it's too dangerous that's too
dangerous to let go you can't let that
stuff happen behind closed doors you
cannot do that that's like letting
letting Germany arm itself in 1936 you
just can't it's too much it's too much
power for tech companies we've got to do
something and that's something I think
is make them free their software code at
least that's one idea but but Ian what
if you're trapped on a road in a
wildfire and you need to contact
emergency services
I want to know if they're tracking me
that's all I still want the tech I do
want the tech does Facebook still have
that thing where you can mark yourself
safe if you're somewhere where there's
an emergency like I remember when there
was the um one of the bombings in Paris
I had a bunch of friends who were
studying abroad there when I was in
college and they marked themselves safe
on Facebook or because people would take
to their Facebook to be like yeah it's
the fastest way to let as many people
know that you're okay dude with all of
that stuff happening no one is going to
give up their devices I'm sitting here
with this smart watch on my wrist that
not only tracks my location probably but
literally my heartbeat
there's gonna be like some nefarious
actor in government they're going to be
like can you pull up Tim Paul's
heartbeat real quick yeah I'm watching
it in real time right now as we speak
and they want to be like why didn't you
see this all right well we put some uh
polonium in his food we want to see if
it's working dude oh more about what
stresses you out than I will even though
I'm the one that's talking to you
because they'll be watching your your
metrics in real time as I'm talking to
you and they'll watch your blood
pressure go up and go oh Ian's really
pissing him off now oh so so Tim does it
like when these things are said with
this tone and then the AI starts to come
in and feel bro you think they can lie
detector with these things
well what I'm wondering is like if it's
hooked up to your phone or something if
it's sending the data to an app on your
phone and the your phone is sending out
all your data to who even knows where
because I obviously don't understand any
of this uh if you're going to start
getting targeted ads for like high blood
pressure medication or something else
like that blood pressure is really good
well if you have some other health
ailment that they can tell from the
watch like if they'll use that data to
start being like Oh we know what to give
him like you'll get a coffee ad when it
tells that you're tired or something
like that like yeah but it seems crazy
it does that though it does that already
and it's not just ads because you know
people say oh it's just because they
want to give you targeted ads like you
said those videos today that's not
advertising anything it's just almost
subliminally pushing something on you so
whether that's transgender ideology uh
right wing or left-wing politics if it's
pushing that on you all the time it's
more than just that that is influencing
your political beliefs that is
influencing you know every aspect of
your life you don't know where it's
coming from it's sort of like we don't
know the cause of this Wildfire if you
it's you know Chris Burton one of our
writers the story up about a student
meeting with the guidance counselor to
school in Florida and the guidance
counselor basically being like perhaps
you are a transgender and then you can
see where the cause sort of comes from
or who what one of the major factor was
but if it's if it's the algorithm it's
stuff that seems innocuous to you you
know it's almost harder to say I'm gonna
pull myself out of it kids have no idea
they have no idea I've talked about this
we talked about a while ago that an
adult who gets fed nonsense is going to
have some level of Defense being like
hey that's not reality if if you know
you go to an adult and say two plus two
is five the average adult says are you
is that a joke like no it isn't and they
understand the logical system of you
know two and two is four but you go to a
young person you show them an algorithm
you tell them things they don't quite
understand
it fractures their their logical
capabilities I think the two plus two
equals five thing from the left is a
really really great example of the
assault on young people and how they're
trying to hobble the minds of the Next
Generation
because if you can understand basic math
then your brain has a way to calculate
lots of things Beyond just two plus two
equals four you'll be able to do your
finances better you'll be able to run a
business better but if you think two
plus two equals five how are you gonna
how are you gonna run a business how are
you gonna how you're gonna manage a bank
account there these people are gonna
grow up and be completely incapable of
doing this stuff and that's what the
algorithm is targeting with all this
weird garbled nonsense it's shattering
the minds in the developmental stage of
these young people and Ali knows it
better than anybody else it's going to
result in people being uh seriously
harmed well exactly and you know most of
these videos that we see on Twitter if
these crazy transactions fists or
sharing their transition Journey
injecting hormones they're all from Tick
Tock right so Tick Tock is really
driving this algorithm and it's owned by
China so it's in China's interest to try
and weaken Generation Z and weaken that
uh you know society and push these
gender identities because you know what
happens if there's world war three how
are we gonna fight if we're too busy
fighting over pronouns or you know dying
our hair purple and screaming about
trans rights you know so it's really
breaking down westernized society and
this is really a westernized problem
because you don't see this on the
Chinese version of tick tock you see
patriotism you see skill sharing
education it's happening in America and
it's happening in Europe and this I
believe it's targeted by the algorithm
it's pushing on very young
impressionable kids these ideas and
shaping their minds to want to be
confused and you know they're going to
grow up now with no concept of reality
like you said two plus two equals five
it's very much George Orwell and kids
have no grasp or of reality they can't
even say what a woman is and that that
just says it all it's really in
community I would think because they
instead of seeking social connections
and you know a sense of community from
their peers they're looking for the
likes online and I think I mean I've
heard the story repeated but of course
you might be able to speak to it more
more specifically of kids feeling out of
themselves having questions about they
are the super normal developmentally and
online sort of getting steered toward
feeling affirmation people who are like
well if you start wearing a dress it it
might make you feel better and wow you
look great and then they sort of pursue
uh more gender ambiguous Lifestyles
because they feel like that's where they
are the most accepted because that's
where they're getting the actual like
this the serotonin boost yeah and that's
what kids want at the end of day
validation and you know Tick Tock came
about around the same time as the
pandemic so you had kids not socializing
if they were going to school they were
wearing masks they weren't having those
key and vital communication skills with
other kids and a lot of them were at
home on Zoom calls so they lost that so
they went to social media like Tick Tock
to try and find that outlet and find
that validation and love and praise and
you know you notice with um people that
transition and share their Journey on
Tick Tock they start off doing something
very simple you know putting a bit of
makeup on and suddenly the likes and
comments and engagement goes up yeah and
then the more and more extreme they show
the more views and attention they get so
I think for a lot of them it's seeking
that validation and trying to find that
love because they don't feel it inside
they don't feel that love for themselves
and Dylan Morgan is a great example you
know starting out just as an actor as a
guy trying anything he could to be
famous and suddenly becomes more and
more extreme the things he says become
more shopping tampons he wants to be a
lesbian he wants to be pregnant and I
think it's almost
um a race to get get the most craziest
videos the more views and stuff because
it makes that person feel validated and
I think you know a lot of kids are
falling into that trap yep how did you
break out of it it's actually really
hard so I still do Tick Tock very
occasionally but I used to be on it
eight hours a day like I was really
addicted to tick tock and and that's why
the algorithm was just feeding me
constantly transgender things non-binary
things all of that stuff so it led me to
be very confused and think you know
maybe this is a sign from the Universe I
didn't think oh it's the algorithm
pushing this something I thought okay
maybe the universe the universe it's the
universe or it's God or something you
know telling me this is who I meant to
be so um you know I just stopped using
it and you know I still use social media
I use Twitter you know for sharing news
stories and stuff but I just realized
social media can be quite narcissistic
and it's like we've become so consumed
with how we look online and I just
thought you know it I don't care
what I look like anymore I don't care
what people say I'm just gonna try and
use my platform to help people so I
think you know spending less time on
apps like you know Instagram and Tick
Tock and stuff really really helped and
you know we all love social media but I
think you know maybe don't don't get too
into it because it can actually change
who we really are that's been on my mind
a lot lately I've been hyper obsessed
with my personal life and I'm just like
seeing it kind of from the outside I
think it's been 20 years of this the
social media age like I am a narcissist
and I can't stand it I don't like
checking how many likes I got how many
subscribers do I have did that person
like what did she what did she like what
did he say like it's just this weird
internal Focus that if there is a
nuclear war I'm not prepared for because
I'm focused on my feelings and like I
need to get away so you just said you
stepped away from the actual machine or
at least from aspects of the machine
itself and it was only just extrication
that was the solution you didn't find
any solution like using it smarter or
anything like that I mean I just limit
my use so you know I tend to use Twitter
more than you know Instagram's about
posting pictures of yourself tick tocks
about posting kind of weird things about
your identity and I just realized that
was actually harmless and also
meaningless as well because you know how
am I helping people by just posting
pictures of myself so I realize you know
use a different platform that's helping
people so Twitter you can raise
awareness of issues in the world you can
share news stories I think it's a better
outlet and it's not you know Twitter's
not about posting pictures of yourself
it's about you know sharing stories
sharing news and communicating with
people in the world and you know trying
to talk about these issues so I think
you know limiting my time on those other
apps and you know spending more time
doing positive things like on Twitter
has helped did you go through like a
withdrawal like could you when you
realized that what was happening was it
called turkey or did you have to sort of
walk yourself down from because eight
hours a day how do you get anything else
done I know well that was just on Tick
Tock and then I'll be on Instagram for a
few hours and stuff but it's almost like
it's a whole work day it's a whole work
day it's almost like it was your job you
you are it is yeah so it is my job so
you know I was getting brand deals and
stuff but it's it's like an opioid
because you get so addicted so when you
try to slow that down you can't like
even when I'm so exhausted and tired you
know I'd be on my phone like at night
it's 2 A.M three I'm it's so boring on
my phone Nothing Gonna I'd still be on
it I couldn't get off so it you know I'm
an adult but imagine these kids that are
on Tick Tock they see all these cool
Trends and these identities and they've
maybe they don't have friends at school
maybe they're loners and they go to this
for an outlet and it's that validation
we all check how many likes we get how
many comments subscribe drivers we have
that addiction to you know feeling
validated and feeling like if we have
more followers we're loved we're a good
person but it shouldn't be about that it
should be about who we are inside and
you know it doesn't matter if we have a
million followers or 10 followers it's
about the quality of the people around
us what reinforces that is the money
that can come along with the followers
man what a what a kerfuffle and what
money gets you yeah so the people who
are getting more likes are now posting
cooler and cooler things I remember when
I was when social media first started
coming out I would see these posts from
people that looked so awesome and here I
am sitting in my you know in my living
room or whatever say my computer my
family's my my parents house when I was
on like 15 16. and I'm seeing people
like they got their skateboards in their
car and they're like they have selfies
or whatever digital cameras placed in
the dashboard they were bigger back then
and I'm just like man so lucky like all
this cool stuff they're doing they
weren't doing any of that stuff it was
like they were going to the grocery
store and they made it look like they're
doing something fun it was all fake it
was all these highlights I reel of
people's boring lives and within a few
years I realized I I realized that I'm
going on these Mission skating and I'm
hanging out these people I'm always
boring like all that stuff they were
posting was just exaggerated to make it
look like they were doing something cool
I think I'm fortunate enough to me those
of us who grew up you know one foot and
one foot out of of this social media
space recognize that it's one big facade
but you've got kids who are growing up
and it being told that it's legit the
people who are making money off it are
living these glamorous lives and now
there was that that poll we talked about
a few years ago
in China the number one job kids say
they want to be when they grow up
astronaut in the United States YouTuber
man I wonder but there are there's a
decline in Factory workers in China
right now and they're attributing
largely the fact that social media has
made it seem like there are actually
other things to do so if you grew up
without social media without access to
the internet you'd be like well everyone
I know works in the factory and so I'm
gonna work in the factory and now it's
like but I don't want to do that they're
also more Highly Educated than their
parents and things like that but I I
think that's the thing that we want to
say social media gives you like
something to dream about like you watch
someone's travel Vlog they go to Iceland
it's cool you think I'm gonna plan a
trip to Iceland and that could be
positive on the other hand it's very
easy to become a place of jealousy and
bitterness and envy I feel like uh
people will be really disappointed when
they go and see in the Aurora Borealis
these photos are always manipulated
people don't get it uh the Milky Way for
instance if you Google search a photo of
the Milky Way you see this dark band of
color these are like high dynamic range
photos multi-layer multi you know
aperture or whatever to make it really
vibrant and then you go out I remember
the first time I went to the Mojave and
I was like we're gonna go to the Mojave
like we're in Vegas we're gonna drive
out and we're gonna go to the middle of
nowhere and just look at the Milky Way
and it's like I can kind of see it okay
you mentioned it's all fake you
mentioned the the uh the the that data
point of out of China the kids want to
be astronauts and out of the US they
want to be YouTubers and I wonder it's
the first time this crossed my mind if
those if that's a fake result that the
CCP is telling everyone like oh no no
our citizen kids want to be astronauts
yeah they all just want to be YouTubers
yeah uh they want to be um what what is
what is what is the app called in uh
China you've got do Yen um you've got
WeChat which is a bit like WhatsApp or a
bit like X like Twitter and you've got
durian and is what's that other big one
they've got there's Billy Billy it's
like some Tick Tock kind of thing and
there's we both yeah that's a big one
yeah yeah well let's let's jump to the
uh the international context here I have
this tweet from kim.com he tweeted this
video from Russian American Daily
Russian defense minister NATO assembled
000 troops in eastern Europe Poland is
preparing to occupy Western Ukraine this
is the perspective of Russia you can
call them wrong you call them lies you
call propaganda call it whatever you
want but we do know that Poland is
sending another 2 000 troops to
reinforce this border with Belarus we do
know that Joe Biden is calling Reserve
forces I already did to be deployed into
Europe and there is a very real concern
Chinese and Russian warships conduct
highly provocative drills near Alaska
that uh I don't know World War III so
take your pick there's good reason for
Chen to be attacking us from the inside
to destabilize the United States and
there's a very real possibility that
we're about to escalate into World War
III I say about to but who knows how
long this stuff takes you know it could
take several years or it could be
overnight I feel like it's you know you
have become famous for calling for for I
not World War III I guess Civil War is
normally before he just mentioned I'm
sorry I apologize just occasionally
calling out the words for saying the
phrase but I think again with the
presence of military ships I mentioned
this um I think last week that you know
we have this newly commissioned ship the
Canterbury that's in Australia I think
now more than ever we are seeing this
sort of toe-to-toe escalation in in a
small way it's just hard for me to see
who is going to make that first a truly
aggressive move
um and I think
that's the worst part of War because
we'll look back and be able to say like
oh well this was happening for a long
time but right now we're all sort of
saying like is this it is this happening
and I think China feels very emboldened
to threaten Taiwan for instance when
they look at Joe Biden you know he
doesn't know where he's going he's
falling down all the time and they look
at the breakdown of American society
which in part is thanks to them with you
know Tick Tock and they're push to week
in America so you know China is
emboldened that I think they feel they
can take Taiwan and America won't
respond because we've seen you know so
many red lines cross like in Syria when
the red line was crossed with chemical
weapons and Obama threatened to do
something but he didn't
um you know we've seen things in Ukraine
as well so I think China is moving
closer and closer and you have to think
as well China has huge investments in
African countries
um uh they have that Island what's that
island called Diego Garcia which I
believe is owned by the UK they're
actually giving that back to I believe
it's Mauritius so China could
potentially take that as a base
um in the Pacific so you see China's
building the military they're building
the islands and we're when they look at
America and they see you know Joe Biden
a nation in Decline it just emboldens
them let's get conspiratorial we have
this big fire in Maui they don't know
how it started wow I'm sure it's going
to turn out to be like someone's cow
kicked over a lantern or something like
that to be to be honest however we do
have this story from back in February
China flashed mysterious Green Lasers
over Hawaii NASA says you guys remember
this this is like the first thing I
thought of when like you have these
lasers Sky barcode yeah wow and uh why
by the way and what look at that yo look
at this video
the light and on fire with that
language
look at that my bad what are they doing
with these beams of lasers
being fired over Hawaii they're either
Purdue they're producing heat because
that's what lasers are they're either
doing illumination or targeting scanning
or heating yeah scanning Maybe
and you you can if you notice you can
only see the lasers in certain points
I don't believe that China intended for
these lasers to be seen something
particulate matter causes refraction
allowing you to see the lasers in in the
air
um maybe we haven't followed up in the
story maybe there was an answer as to
what this was they say China's most
likely behind the mysterious lights
Chinese pollution monitoring satellite
daki 1 probably produced the light spot
over Hawaii
oh so it's monitoring pollutions oh you
can call whatever you want but my
attitude is you look we are not we are
not on good terms with China right now I
mean we can we can pretend oh no trade's
going on everything's fine no come on
they want Taiwan they're building up
their military there's a chance for
escalation a chance for conflict they
want the South China Sea and then
they've got ships with Russia coming
near the Illusions coming near U.S
territory going near Hawaii and then
they're pulling off something like this
so look how hard is it to start a fire
it's ridiculously easy to start a fire
and they can fire lasers okay
it's a little challenging to get the
fire to spread but there were hurricane
level it said it was like hurricane
level winds or there's I don't I don't I
don't have high winds if they can start
50 fires what all at once with the
sequence of satellites doing High burst
high energy laser lasers then getting
fire to spread isn't really the issue
because you make the fire instantly in a
bunch of different places and they can
monitor the weather in Hawaii I mean you
could just Google that like what I was
reading from the national Guardsman
who's making a statement was that you
know there's low humidity and high winds
so that's perfect conditions for
wildfires to spread which means any
arson fires would also spread as quickly
like China is perfectly able to say like
this happens to be a dangerous period
for fire in Hawaii perhaps now if if
they were to do something uh there was
also a Chinese balloon observed in
Internet above international waters near
Hawaii February 2022. wow all right
right yeah yeah so it does seem like
obviously they have they have a targeted
interest in Hawaii uh and remember when
Marjorie Taylor green argued that there
were like space lasers that could start
fires maybe she was right I think it's
really funny because they claimed she
said Jewish space lasers when she
mentioned like uh Rothschild's Bank was
providing funding for certain technology
or whatever and I'm like well I don't
know about any of that but I can tell
you that we have video of lasers being
fired from satellites their argument
came from a pollution monitoring
satellite but lasers did come from this
this satellite now I don't know the
capabilities of this but uh
I'm not gonna believe them right I'm not
gonna believe China's like I just we're
looking for pollution in Hawaii well and
they said the balloon that went over
Montana was like oh it was monitoring
the weather and it blew off course and
we didn't say anything like so I don't
want to be too mean to China right now
but they lie I mean they're declining to
meet with our secretary of state or
there are any delegations for like from
Anton Anthony blink blinken so what
makes us think that they're feeling like
they should give us any honest
information right I think I think
Ollie's right there is a there is a
uh General opinion coming from China
that America is not in a position of
strength I mean I remember being on pop
culture at the end pop culture crisis
the podcast uh at the end of this last
year and uh we were talking about the
fact that China was declining more
western movies I mean they are not
interested in American culture right now
and in fact to your point they're
probably trying to insulate themselves
from American culture because American
culture uh modern American culture is
largely about the destruction and and
the Turning within oneself and there's
no page there's a lack of Civic
engagement it makes the country weak and
so in turn it makes their adversaries uh
Stronger they're saying that it may have
been Cloud aerosol lidar and infrared
Pathfinder satellite observation Calypso
good job with that one guys path it's
been orbiting for more than 15 years so
maybe it's nothing but I can tell you
this space lasers are real
confirmed we know Popular Mechanics we
know about space lasers lasers can start
fires the question is would it what is
the potentiality for China to have any
kind of of laser on a satellite that can
produce enough energy to start a fire
would they do it against us I think this
is all easily within the realm of
possibility that they can damage our
economy and Us in major areas
and make it look like an accident
it's uh I guess fifth generational
Warfare yeah first thought I had was
let's get cash Patel in here and talk
about high-tech weaponry and see what
he's not going to tell everyone what the
American government has necessarily but
he'll be able to smile and Nod while
we're talking about these things hey man
that's it if we need to be on guard I I
don't say
believe everything or have an open mind
to the point where your brain falls out
like not everything is possible
everything's possible well I love that
image your mind is so open your brain
Falls have you ever seen it's a meme I
didn't make it up but there's like a me
but the guys thinking and then it thinks
yeah
um keep it in mind though yeah space
lasers are legit real and they can make
things very very hot I think the
question is
what's the point of the timing like at
what point do we think that anyone would
want yeah just chaos well I mean if if
if if we're busy dealing with if China
China invades Taiwan tomorrow then we'll
get it right so this is this is a target
this is a a Pacific
economic Hub and Naval bases and they
just did military training the Chinese
and Russians a few days ago up by the
Aleutian Islands right and the U.S
deployed warships and now all of a
sudden unknown fire Sparks and wipes out
a whole city I mean the damage that we
see in this city Only 53 dead thank
heavens because it was just a fire
but this wiped out basically the whole
city that's a if if that is a weapon
that is a powerful weapon
God like dude it the reality is we've
got videos online of the us having large
infrared lasers
that can shoot down drones it Heats them
up until they burst into flames and then
they fall out of the sky
with a satellite
I don't know how long it would take to
to get a charge for a laser powerful
enough to start to start a fire but you
don't I mean the range is probably the
issue I mean we're talking what is it 50
miles what what's uh what's a what's a
low earth orbit satellite probably 150
miles someone you want to go back real
quick
that's a long distance for something to
start a fire so I I don't know it seems
that seems like a bit much to be
completely honest uh your own Theory
right now between 160 kilometers and 2
000 kilometers wow so even less than
that so right so it could be like 60
miles 70 miles
can is there a laser that can start a
fire within 60 miles I kind of feel like
military attack is well like Way Beyond
what we think and even if it was like a
rail gun that launched a small
incendiary or something it's easier than
or like 10 lasers to like times ten if
you can if for the distance right made
it hotter and focusing in One Direction
the question is how much energy would
need to to store to be able to pull
something like that at that range and it
may be maybe it takes seven months to
charge up with solar and then it can set
off a couple small fires something who
knows but you all you got this you also
got the fires up in Canada yeah so
what's what's going on now they're going
to claim climate change and all that
stuff I'm sure but what if the reality
is war
well there was um wildfires in Greece
recently and um some investigative
reporters found that the land that was
burnt was already had a permit to build
wind farms but the locals didn't want
them to build there so that could be one
explanation that's it's purposeful arson
so that land developers can buy the land
cheap and get in there and you know and
claim it's climate change but really
it's just them trying to see some land
for a cheap price let's get uh even more
spicy tonight we have this from the post
millennial man-made climate change is
manufactured consent driven by profit
motive claims climate science climate
change scientists who said the ipcc was
set up to look for Dangerous
human-caused climate change this is a
controversial interview John Stossel did
they say post money reports once during
uh once a one Starling of the climate
alarmism Community turned skeptic Judith
Curry told John Stossel that the
man-made climate change narrative as a
manufactured consensus because
researchers found that they could make
money pushing it the video released on
Tuesday pointed out how some scientists
take aggressive attempts to High data
that shows that climate change isn't a
crisis she said they do ugly things just
avoiding Freedom of Information after
quests trying to get Journal editors
fired the origins go back to the UN
environmental program Curry said she
noted that some U.N officials were
motivated by anti-capitalism they hated
the oil companies and seized in the
climate change issue to move their
policies along she pointed to the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change ipcc which was set up quote to
look for Dangerous human-caused climate
change and not focus on any benefits of
warming so I'll pause right there and
and my question then is if obviously a
lot of people are going to agree with
her I don't immediately agree with her
because I don't immediately agree with
any of these people I don't care if
they're the ipcc or otherwise
what was she saying that there are
benefits of climate change of man-made
global warming but also that it's
alarmism it's not a crisis as you're
saying it's not a crisis because there
are benefits in which case the
implication is it's actually happening
you get it
no I'm gonna need to hear that one okay
she's saying that it's alarmism because
they can make money
and that they're not pointing out the
benefits of warming that sounds like
what she's saying is climate change is
real humans are causing it but the
reason that it's not a crisis is because
we benefit from it
she thinks the scientists are just being
too negative they're being too hard on
man-made clients that's what it sounds
like
I mean I I tend to agree with you know
anything becomes a crisis if someone
realizes they can make money off of
offering you a solution right like all
the companies that have sprung up and
are able to be like you should buy our
product because it's no emissions or
it's recycled or whatever else even when
maybe actually producing that product in
the quote-unquote greenway this concept
of green washing is actually more
harmful to the environment or whatever
it's from I mean we hear the stories
about you put in wind farms or fields of
solar panels and you're actually killing
everything that lives naturally in that
field but does it matter like are we
saying that's not worth it
um but it's hard to know exactly what
her Christmas is I don't know of any
benefits of global warming but I also
plants grow faster I guess
I feel like
I don't know it's nicer in the summer we
can we can reclaim Antarctica yeah I
believe the Ice Age which is probably
pretty cool but I think if the planet
ever got hot enough to wear Antarctica
melted we could reclaim it the the
equator would probably be uninhabitable
the Middle East would be gone you know
we'd be we'd be living on the on the
caps and there'd be a band in the center
of the earth that's too hot to live
there's that one of the Larson B ice
shelf I think broke off as Antarctic ice
shelf isn't that a TV show Larson B no
no the TV show where the equator has
become global warming has resulted in
the in the equator region the equator
region like around the planet being too
hot so there are southern hemisphere
people and Northern Hemisphere people
and it's very difficult to travel
between the two hemispheres because of
the heat in the middle but it reminds me
of like the
there's some Show on Netflix recently
like different fantasy novels will have
these concepts of like War like kingdoms
that are separated by some place that's
very difficult to cross like maybe we've
been predicting this for a long time uh
the thing about all climate science and
I'm happy to try and protect the Earth
or you know not import
non-native species and whoever take
steps to protect the environment that
you're living in it just seems like the
metrics behind climate science change a
lot like with a thing that we're
concerned about
changes like one time I came on here I
was like aren't we concerned about the
ozone layer and everyone was like no the
ozone layer was trendy but now it's over
like how do I keep up with knowing how
to protect the environment if the thing
that they're saying is the most pressing
pressing danger changes all the time big
problem with climate science it's like
if you had a thousand people taking a
poop and you're like at this rate we're
gonna have huge huge mounds of poop and
we're all gonna die make them stop
pooping we need less people and you're
like well what if we move the poop over
there and afterwards no well we hadn't
considered that we don't consider
mitigating factors we just look at the
cause and unmitigated result and we'll
project that number out for x amount of
years infinite amounts of years and
we'll tell you that in 100 000 years
this will be the result they don't take
into account that we can pull the gases
back out of the atmosphere for instance
which would be like redisplacing the the
waste
uh did that answer your question I don't
know I think so like like I I remember
taking an environmental science course
like an AP environmental science course
when I was in high school and it being
like the we talked about this the other
week about the light bulbs they're like
the new LED light bulbs are gonna change
the world and they're so important and
this that and the other but now I never
hear about the light bulbs now I hear
about ocean levels now also I think the
ocean levels are over because all the
billionaires bought their beach houses
which is evidenced by the Maui map and
also from what I knew about ice and
water and volume it all sort of works
out if the ice melts but again maybe I'm
wrong and a lot of these green
technologies for instance wind turbines
in Scotland they got rid of 15 million
trees they basically deforested them to
make way for wind farms so you have that
then you have the Cobalt and lithium
mines in Congo which are for electric
batteries for solar panels for cars and
they have to be replaced every year and
that causes tremendous uh pollution not
only that there's a lot of child slave
but there's about 20 000 child slaves
mining these for solar panels so I think
you know all the people these scientists
that preach about we need to push wind
turbines we need all these solar panel
knows it's very hypocritical because it
oftentimes these things actually cause
more environmental damage no deforesting
entire natural habitats and so I really
think what this scientist was saying it
is being used for profit to scare people
and you know if this was true if it
really was the world's about to explode
from global warming why are these
billionaires going on 2000 private jets
to Davos for the world economic Forum
every single year so they don't practice
what they preach so it can't be that bad
if they're saying the world's about to
end yet they're still on their vacation
on their private jet in their five
different Mansions five different
Mansions aren't on property right yeah
now they're going to come out they're
going to say Maui was climate change
this proves it and we're all going to be
like why do you own 900 Acres on Maui if
you think Maui's Going Up in Flames
because of climate change when I was in
LA in like 2009 I was so freaked out by
a lot of this climate stuff and I would
start screaming and telling guys to pee
in the sink because I was like I'm tired
stop wasting water we're in a drought
and so I made a YouTube video I was like
PM that you're a man pee in the sink
don't waste water looking back like was
that gross or did I do the right thing
WP and the sink like hopefully you clean
it after yeah
top and bottom toilets some people call
them I guess and these environmentalists
it's a two-level toilet where when
you're going number one you sit on the
top which fills it up and then when you
go number two the number one flushes the
number two cool people do not understand
so a lot of people don't get this
anybody who's owned an RV gets this when
you use the toilet there is a pool of
water in there that's a diluting human
waste concentrated you know in its
natural form these these hippies they're
they're they're well they're making a
sacrifice I got to tell you did you ever
get an unintended whiff
I've never used one of those toilets oh
yeah that's in yours you didn't use it
what do you mean your RV did you not
have toilet you don't smell these things
in the RV when you drain them that's
what I meant did you ever you never
bothered I've never used them okay but
uh these environmental toilets is like
you CL you stand on the top you know you
sit on the top and you fill it up
yourself
and then you sit down on the bottom and
there you go I'm just not that dedicated
to see hey look California's in a
drought yeah they've been in a dread I
don't know if they're still in a drought
but the drought comes and goes basically
Southern California is a desert and
they're only surviving off of Colorado
River water for the most part so hey
there's these people who live down there
are like I shouldn't have to do this
everyone else should have to and it's
like dude they would have swimming pools
don't they so if there's such a drought
you know give up your swimming pool for
the summer well there were several
celebrities that were running their
Sprinklers and they would get fined so
they were just doing it anyway because
they can afford to pay the fine so why
should their lifestyle suffer uh but you
guys should all start using you know
reusable pla or like the paper straws
because that will save the environment
and that's ridiculous because you go to
Starbucks you get a coffee it's in a
massive plastic cup and then you've got
the paper straw which is just you know
so hypocritical so it's just virtue
signaling at the end of the day because
how's that saving the planet if you're
still using a plastic that was because
they found that tortoise that giant
turtle with the straw stuck in his nose
did you ever see that video yeah and
they have like pliers trying to pull it
out it's bleeding I spent a lot of time
cutting up the like plastic rings for
soda cans because of those images of
like various things that would swim
through don't get stuck it was super
upsetting I didn't like that at all but
then you know we don't talk about the
fact that you can order mixed
wildflowers off of Amazon and throw all
this or like the seeds of them all over
your yard and actually all of the plants
are native to China so you're actually
hurting your local biome because it's
not clearly marked but the
environmentalist environmentalists don't
care about that but they do care about
like none of it makes sense to me there
doesn't seem to be any consistency I
learned recently that dandelions are not
native to North America and they're
actually not weeds they're considered
medicinal and food and they were brought
here intentionally and now they're weeds
oh wow we should eat we should start
eating those yeah there's like there's
like a short season for it honestly it's
like a couple weeks where the dandelions
are all out everywhere and then what
they would do is that when they were
bright and yellow they would fry them
yeah it's like it's like a West Virginia
delicacy
I love the movement towards uh people
will grow native plants instead if you
have like a big yard instead of having
just grass you you grow native plants so
you can have native pollinators I think
that's sort of this idea of the tract
home and the probably UK has an
equivalent of this that are built and at
the time they were a symbol of
prosperity and you're you can own your
own home and that's great but they all
had to have the exact same lawn and
there's no sort of a maintenance and
there's sort of a an aesthetic a purpose
to it turned us away from being part of
our environment here's what's crazy
we have a ridiculous amount of fruit on
the property bangs I've never even heard
of Greenbrier
no idea what that is and uh you know I I
go out by the shed and there's this
these vines with these like little
bushels of like berries hanging from the
tree and I'm like what is this so I have
this app called picture this scan it and
then it says this is Greenbrier an
edible Blackberry I was like how come
I've never gone to the grocery store and
grabbed things like oh it's blueberries
raspberries strawberries and mostly due
to uh
uh sturdiness of the of the fruit so
pawpaw for instance why don't we why
can't you buy Papa in the grocery store
why because it's very hard to cultivate
it's very hard to pollinate it becomes
very delicate and it rots really quick
so most people never heard of pawpaw
then we've got uh like everyone knows
mulberries because there's a song about
it but how many people have actually had
Mulberry you if you have a mulberry tree
you'll have mulberries in the summer but
they're so delicate and they break
nobody harvests them and ships them out
even though there's like a tree produces
an ungodly amount of them it's weird how
people how the English how just humans
are like we have the blueberry and it's
like there's lots of berries that are
blue but that's the blueberry and
there's the Blackberry then there's the
orange like there's other fruits that
are orange but that's the orange orange
got its name like the color orange got
its name from the fruit oh interesting
yeah but and then I was just saying I
watched a grasshopper hop across the
lawn I was like a Grass Hopper he's
hopping on the grass like oh we're so
smart these humans like we're just so
brilliant the words come into existence
so like it's so childish
but peoples and people's names mean
things people used to name their kids
the equivalent of like Shining Light I
will name my Chon worships the Lord
Puritan name Trends those were fun I
don't know like my name means one who is
like what is it uh one who is judged by
God and then Daniel means one who is uh
one who honors God or might be the
inverse but quite literally back in the
day there's some dude who had a kid and
it's like what would you like to name
your son one who is judged by God but
how did it become going to Tim how did
it how did it that no that meant Timothy
meant judge Bible okay
I guess I used to like the Puritans uh
would name their kids like negative
things so that you would like remember
things you shouldn't be doing so they
have some really crazy names somebody
should look them up or I'll do it in a
second uh because we think of like oh
you know you might name your daughter
Grace because of God's grace or
something like that but they would say
their kids like just these things like
he who shouldn't sin or something like
that like these sort of heavy dark names
because they were trying to remind their
kids to stay like on the right path yeah
so you will look at Sorry God Tim Mateos
means honoring God
timateos honoring God that's where
Timothy comes from but my point is like
people literally used to just be very
direct with everything but my point
about the food is that people who live
in cities don't know what food is and
it's really fascinating when they come
out here and they're like did you plant
this I get asked that for every single
thing from like literally every time
someone who who's never lived out in the
middle of nowhere comes out and then
I'll be like hey look we have a bunch of
wine Berry I'm like what's wineberry and
I'm like well it's like a Chinese kind
of raspberry but did you plant this I'm
like I'm like dude there's eight
thousand uh brambles just everywhere and
you think like we went with seeds and we
planted all of them yeah and there and
the grapes are everywhere we've there's
hundreds of thousands of grapes I'm not
even kidding hundreds of thousands all
along this tree line and people like did
you plant them I'm like that that grape
vine is 20 feet in the air where would I
have planted that to me I don't know
what you're talking I was thinking we
should make wine and I'm like you know
the amount of effort and work it would
take to make wine where we just go to
the store and spend 150 bucks on bottles
of wine is like so out of proportion
right now that I do think we're living
in like this luxurious society that
can't sustain it just can't like we
should be prioritizing The Grapes on the
property and making the wine it would be
fun like this idea of like the farm to
table or eat local movement is
interesting the problem is that people
go to the grocery store and the grocery
stores don't stock local produce then
obviously it becomes hard to eat the
stuff like there there is a challenge to
it I think you know when we had more
Regional Food Systems meaning that
farmers ship their foods to local
grocery stores we probably had more
diversity in our diet which is
interesting and there was probably more
Regional Cuisine right like we're
talking about like stuff that's in West
Virginia if you probably went back and
found like an old West Virginia cookbook
they used things that were in the area
it was different and now we still have
sort of a homogeneous culture across the
U.S if you go to any grocery store you
expect to see a certain things
homogenization of the world and it's
horrifying like I've talked about how I
went to the Bahamas I went to Nassau and
I'm like this is going to be cool I'm
going to see some some local flavor and
I get off the boat and it's like Gucci
Hard Rock Cafe Starbucks and I'm just
like why okay I guess I got a Starbucks
down the street for me I need to come
here for this maybe that's the intention
maybe that's what they want but uh they
have this service where you can get
shipped exotic fruits and most people
don't even know what these things are
because you go to the grocery store and
there's like seven fruits you can buy
and then sometimes there's like a
prickly pear and people like ooh look at
this weird one and it's just like dude
there's so much crazy stuff going on we
have Blackberry black cherry trees the
black cherries are in season right now
so there's probably on One Tree or what
is there 200 000 black cherries it's
crazy I don't even know how to get them
they're just like all the way in the top
40 feet in the air yeah we need like a
machine that you latch around the trunk
and then it just vibrates yep and they
all fall down have you seen that video
of like a truck that does it with
oranges uh but I think what you're
saying is probably because the idea that
things are in season like you can't get
them all the times and Americans
probably just all mod modern Western
culture we expect things now and we
don't want to have to wait like you can
get strawberries in the grocery store
all year round they have a growing
season we just grow them in greenhouses
no that's an innovation that's pretty
cool on the other hand what are we
missing out on because we've simplified
our minds to only expect to eat
strawberries this is why a lot of the
climate change stuff doesn't bother me
when they're like you shouldn't be
getting avocados in the winter and I'm
like yeah I I agree with that it's like
ridiculous that we grow avocados in
Mexico and then we ship them to New York
for a bunch of hipsters so they can have
their winter avocado toast like just
have the fruit and stuff that's
available in your region in these times
now I get it I get it in winter you need
to ship food in because they're not
growing this stuff but I just think
generally
I am I am slightly offended by Urban
liberals who are complaining about
climate change while being the primary
beneficiaries of of the you know the the
gas guzzling imperialism right right
it's like it's like dude it's you it's
not the dude who's got a bunch of
chickens in Appalachia who's eating
pawpaw and who's he's not getting pawpaw
shipped to him from Mexico and he's
preserving stuff so that in the winter
he'll have some type of fruit yeah we
made wineberry Jam exactly it's great we
saved it's still good it's a different
culture mulberry jam too right it's it's
a cultural difference of having to think
like I'm going to have to think ahead
I'm going to have to plan what I'm going
to eat in the winter so I have something
we're we're much more of an on-demand
Society now of course I benefit from
that I go to the grocery store like I
there are things that I enjoy in
modernity not having to prep food and
farm all summer and things like that on
the other hand like as a culture what
did we lose when we wanted the
convenience we lost the sense of
appreciation and value you know because
when we have a meal we don't appreciate
where has that come from you know who
picked that from the tree so I think
that's why it's nice to grow locally if
you can grow vegetables in your own
garden because you appreciate it and
also the taste is so much better you
know when you grow lettuce or potatoes
and you cook it it tastes beautiful
there's no no harmful chemicals on it
from Monsanto or anything it's just
purely out of the ground so I think
there's a there's something nice about
that appreciating and kind of going back
to you know old times when we used to
grow our own vegetables and you know
everybody if they have a little garden
just grow a few things I think that's a
nice thing do you think there's emotions
involved with vegetables like when you
the way you pick them because I know
with animals if you Slaughter an animal
that's in fear it'll produce a lot of
cortisol the meat won't be as good I've
heard that yeah I know that if I'm
stressed out and I eat food I have a
harder time digesting because I'm
stressed so is the plant is the plant
also experiencing some sort of stressor
and like being frozen and shipped over
long distances held in captivity in a
grocery store
held in captivity not in a spiritual
sense but right now we've got grapes
growing all over the property they're
called Frost grapes and what they say
you're supposed to do is you harvest
them when they're plumpest and freshest
which I think is coming up in a month or
two you freeze them lightly and then
take them out and thaw them and that
causes a chemical reaction which changes
them from very tart to very sweet yeah
so a lot of people wait they're called
Frost grapes you wait till first Frost
and then it converts the sugars or
something like that although a lot I was
I was watching a video about and they're
like some people just don't care all
that much the tartness is actually quite
Pleasant so yeah maybe just want regular
old wild grapes that's sort of nice you
have the option to do either one so I'm
not spiritually emotional but more
chemical chemically reactive that's for
sure chemical reaction occurs I'm I've
just been thinking more and more that
you know cities are the devil you know
in in a certain sense I I've lived in
cities my whole life uh then slowly
started moving further and further away
from them then in 2014 got a little time
like a five acre little plot in in the
Redlands in Miami which was less City
more Rural and uh semi-farm like there's
a lot of farms there we had only five
acres but we had chickens the first time
we got a chicken right out of the
chicken's butt I'm like do I gotta do
anything to it do I just do I just eat
it and then I'm like did we just eat it
then we fried up the eggs they were
great we made food with it then uh when
we were here when we got away from uh
Jersey and New York and all that stuff
we had a garden I wake up in the morning
take two eggs straight from the
chicken's butt you walk right up in the
chicken laser they're still warm and
then you go to the Garden I pick some
cherry tomatoes grab a zucchini go and
chop it all up fry it up breakfast made
by me no harmful chemicals no BS
I think about what's going on in cities
how to feed the the people who live
there glyphosate pesticides atrazine all
of these really awful chemicals the the
the fuels that are burned to produce it
all the waste produced by it and I'm
like that's disgusting it's not food
these people are eating like brominated
flour and other weird chemicals and I'm
like cities have become toxic wastelands
where people are consuming fake food
becoming extremely depressed and
unhealthy that we have a story I mean
suicide rates are through let me pull
this one up let's talk about this
look at this the daily daily mail
reports suicides hit record high last
year when nearly 50 000 Americans took
their own lives CDC report revealed that
suicides in the US aren't an all-time
high I think a large component of this
is what's what we see in cities
obviously covet I think destroyed a lot
of people the lockdowns and all that
stuff but you come out to the middle of
nowhere and what do you have
fresh running water granted you don't
want to drink wild stuff right you got
to clean and all that stuff but we have
a well we have a well water with a
filtration system so there's no Gunk
there's no weird chemicals there's no
there's like there's no chlorine I'm
pretty sure we have no chlorine uh we
just it's like a multi-stage filter with
a with a UV light to clean it and kill
the bacteria no fluoride added just
regular oil well water and it's it's we
have the rivers right down the road
fresh fruit growing all across the
property it's ridiculous every month
there's some new kind of fruit to eat
and we didn't even we even put it there
and you can even eat the leaves nobody
wants to but you can a lot of the grape
leaves we got so much grapes oh we could
wrap stuff yeah you can wrap them and
soak them yeah Chuck was talking about
doing that so we're out here and it's
like a Disney fairy tale little animals
running out with deer on the front
picturesque mountains in the Forefront
with the Clean Air yup you walk out you
look outside you see clean air you see
Mist Rising there's wild turkeys in the
front you could back in the day
I mentioned this they have the guns in
the kitchen the the muskets and I asked
the guy like what's the musket for and
they're like oh when they're cooking
dinner they open the back door shoot a
rodent
throw the rodent in the stew and I'm
like wow that's how they live it's like
you need to go honey just like open the
door and you're waiting you're like
there we go rabbit Bang
so we have wild turkeys in front of the
house all the time
we don't do this but we could literally
just capture killing anyone we have deer
all over the place there's too many deer
actually I hope like the deer need to be
killed right I I'm you know I don't want
to be a dick but there's like 25 of them
and there's poop everywhere and they're
just eating too much so people go out
and they kill them but you could just
eat the deer it's just like the food is
right there in the cities they use all
this crazy chemicals people's heads are
whacked they're on ssris they live in
Cuba they live in these concrete blocks
that smell like sour milk that break
dust coming out of the car all the car
emissions that they walk through to get
from tiny apartment building to the time
because it goes into your apartments too
it's like living in a sewer is it like
that in London too you're from outside
London yeah but I don't really spend
much time there but it is I mean the
pollution is really really bad but you
know on the flip side they're trying to
push the climate change thing so they're
putting plant pots in the middle of
roads to stop drivers going into Central
London they're charging people every
single day about 15 just to drive into
Central London so that's even delivery
drivers truck drivers so there's good
good and bad things about that you know
I think it is uh a tough life there when
people are going from the office you
know nine to five they go straight to
the house and they've got a tiny
apartment and you know for a one bedroom
apartment in London it's like 1 200 1
300 so it's uh you know crammed
conditions a bit like New York so it's
not a way for people to live you know
like Tim was saying it's much better
people are happier and healthier if
they're living in the countryside you
know I spend so much time outdoors and
it's so much nicer it's fulfilling you
know you feel that fresh air and you
feel good and you know you appreciate
things like if you grow your own
vegetables you appreciate that taste you
you don't think oh I can just buy what I
want it's you know consumption it's you
actually enjoy life a bit more yeah
here's the crazy thing the uh they have
a racial breakdown and an age breakdown
it is mostly Millennial white people who
are committing suicide oh my gosh
multiracial people are very low I love
this but what you need to understand is
that white people are the majority of
the population so percentage is what
matters the most
and I think uh who has percentage change
you need to break down the amount of
suicides by race but by percentage of
population so it looks like white people
are committing tremendous amounts of
suicide but it's actually fairly
comparable if you look at black or
African they're about 10 of of of you
know the white population and that's
actually so it seems statistically
average uh suicide across all uh racial
backgrounds but then you you do notice
that from 25 to 64 substantially more
suicides with the highest demographic
being 25 to 44 which is Millennial into
uh uh younger Gen X
it's freaky stuff man you know what
whatever's causing this people are
having a breakdown I think purpose
matters uh I think we can look at a lot
of the issues that are causing something
like this and they're just directly
correlated with cities no community no
neighbors no purpose living in pollution
and garbage and running back and forth
it must it's like it feels
I don't know man it just feels like the
dark side and they can never get out the
latter you know they're stuck in those
jobs for their whole life they're just
surviving based you know paying their
bills and it's really tough and what's
sad as well most these people likely
have mental health struggles and then
you've got Canada that's legalizing
euthanasia including for people with
mental health so how many more people
are going to feel so hopeless that
they're going to take their lives you
know instead of you know sending all
this money to different countries you
know another 24 billion to Ukraine you
know America should be investing in
mental health and let's help these
people we shouldn't be you know pushing
people to you know feel that they've got
no chance in life let's actually help
them and support them with mental health
I think it was someone was just saying
we should reintroduce them reopen mental
facilities was it Vivek was it Vivek do
you guys remember you might it wouldn't
be a bad idea yeah Reagan shut them down
in the early 80s and that was a big
jails instead yeah and now we have this
Mental Health crisis that just began
like right when that big shutdown
happened so maybe it's time to but like
they were so horrible so many people
suffered so horribly in a lot of those
places that that was the justification
for shutting them down but that doesn't
mean that we can't do it right or do
something yeah it also opens the door to
your political dissident so the
government says mentally ill yeah or you
have a medical marijuana card well it's
not federally legal so off to the mental
facility with you and you can't get out
with armed guards yeah with regular
jails you'll get a term
and then you get out maybe you'll get
out with good behavior get out early but
with mental facilities
they determine whether whether you get
out or not I think a lot of these people
are maybe not a lot but returning
veterans from the war in the Middle East
wars in the Middle East when you come
back and you realize like wait there
were no weapons of mass destruction wait
Osama Bin Laden we didn't go into
Afghanistan for Osama Bin Laden I
thought I just spent six to eight years
of my life willing to kill and seeing
people get like
uh and people hate me and look down on
me and think that I'm bad for having
been in the middle I mean like their
veteran suicide is serious and is part
of it I think part of it is also social
media I mean it's something that we see
particularly among young people anywhere
from you know 15 to 35 you're seeing an
increase in anxiety depression suicidal
ideation uh so
there might be a lot of circumstances
but I think ultimately we have bred we
have raised young people in a culture of
hopelessness and you must be reminded
that every day if you're working a job
that you don't like in a city where you
feel like no one knows you and you go
home and you lie in bed and look on your
phone for hours and hours and hours and
you feel like you're not getting the
same amount of likes to someone else and
why aren't you doing more with your life
and that despair is is terrible where I
think we need to have a culture that
measures success not by online presence
but in the connections you have in real
life I think if you look at this data
there's a really easy way to uh a really
easy bit of data to show what's causing
this you can see that males are three
times more likely or three or four times
more likely to commit suicide than
females so I think a large component of
this is telling men they're evil they
are bad they are wrong no matter you
know you know I love there was this
article that talked about the glass
Cliff it was like Linda yaccarino's
appointed to the board of X right when
the company is about to implode this is
the glass cliff and I'm like man you got
a glass floor you got a glass ceiling
got Glass Walls you got a glass Cliff
ladies be living in a big glass room is
that it don't throw stones that's right
that's what I was gonna say people who
live in glass houses shouldn't throw
stones and so these people they'd be
doing nothing but throwing stones and so
I'm like no matter what happens to a
woman in the workplace it is the fault
of patriarchy and men and I'm just like
dude come on you can't be like Elon Musk
hired who he thought was the best person
for the job we were very critical of of
yakarino I think it's the name right
because she was a world economic form
individual
she not being tossed off the glass Cliff
she was given a prestigious position you
give a woman an executive position well
it's the glass Cliff to throw her off
the cliff yeah you don't give a tour
it's also the glass ceiling you get you
you you give her a mid-tier job and they
say well that's the glass floor women
are are thrown out there because they're
eye candy oh just just spare me dude
well I mean with yakarino like them
being like they hire her right as the
company was about to go downhill like
are you guys saying she's not capable of
turning it around yes are you saying
that you think she's not qualified for
the job she was given like are you sort
of showing us what's actually happening
here uh I I think there is such a weird
conversation where women have to be
protected at all costs because they can
never think that maybe a man would have
been better for their position when
ultimately we know that genders are
function differently I mean it goes
right down you can study newborn babies
and see a difference in the way their
brains naturally developed you can't
tell me a newborn baby has been
socialized at all uh we know there are
extreme differences and instead of
having a society that prepares people to
pursue things that fall all along those
lines we're saying constantly like
something's oppressing suppressing you
something's bad actually you're the
problem actually you need to stop the
way you are and conform to what we want
from you it's just toxic I think divorce
is another one I was just watching a
soft white underbelly on YouTube highly
recommend the one with the divorce
attorney that has just recently came out
a few days ago and he was saying that
like in divorce proceedings the guy
tends to get the raw end of the stick
it's like if the guy cheats on the girl
the guy's trash he's a piece of you
know junk if the girl cheats on the guy
the guy probably wasn't doing enough to
support her so she had to go they're
more likely to lose custody of their
children I mean it's and so to be 18 or
16 I mean did you was this around you
this like men are bad is that part of
why you feel like I don't want to be or
I don't feel right as a guy like um so
it wasn't like it is now when you know
the patriarch is constantly mocked and
you saw the Bobby movie that was kind of
mocking men
um so you know you saw the Bob movie
mocking men but um it wasn't around them
but I had a kind of difficult
relationship with my dad he was very
masculine he was trying to get me to do
all these outdoor things and you know I
didn't didn't get on with him so I was
trying to reject that so that was part
of the reason why I became more feminine
and you know more like a girl and stuff
but I think nowadays we're really seeing
this division as you know a breakdown of
masculinity because it's very hard to
find you know just normal masculine guys
now right you know because we're having
a society that's emasculating men and
again the Barbie movie you know I
enjoyed the movie I thought it was cool
I love you know all the colors and the
outfits and stuff but I think it was
mocking men and trying to make men look
bad and tell women you know you don't
need a man you don't need to settle down
and they even mock the pregnant while
being that so I think it's kind of
teaching kids you know or teaching young
girls you don't need a man in life and
you know it's essential for starting a
family right and and growing so um and I
think guys are seeing that and thinking
like uh I'm not needed if they're
telling girls they don't need men and
I'm a man that means I'm not going to be
needed why am I even here I have no
purpose yeah and that's why we don't see
uh strong solid relationships anymore or
marriages you know a lot of marriages
failing or you know people just hooking
up on on apps like Tinder or bumble
because they don't see the purpose of it
you know everything is so fast in modern
society you just got an app you find
someone new so they don't build that
connection which I think is really sad
that was another thing we were talking
about like 50 years ago your pool your
dating pool was like who you knew and
who you were around now even when you're
like married or you're in a fully
committed family relationship if you go
to check your your notifications you see
women's faces like the faces of hundreds
of different women it's just such a like
an erotic mess I it's not it's not
natural stimulation at least it wasn't
up to this now maybe we have to start
considering it I mean it's artificial
but it may be coming part of our nature
but it is counterintuitive to the
marriage mono uh like monogamy structure
that's something else that's divorce
divorce attorney was talking about too
geez what a it's a weird a weird but I
mean if we don't have kids then the
human race will not proceed and this is
why
young men are skewing conservative it's
why young men are fans of Andrew Tate
and Jordan Peterson
because you've got finally they're being
talked to they're being explained their
value they're being explained their
responsibilities their opportunities
and the left this is really really funny
I think it was vosh who's who tweeted
something like the reason young men are
becoming conservatives because the right
is talking to them we need to do this
and the response from all these leftists
was ah boohoo poor man shut up spare me
blah blah blah and I'm just sitting here
laughing being like just keep on ragging
just keep on hating and more and more
guys are gonna be like screw you I'm
leaving
first I was hurt by a girl I blamed her
it was my fault a lot of it went in my
20s so I was like happy to watch this
division proceed in like 2011 12 13 I'm
like good she deserves it all women
deserve it I was so angry and but it's
like a snowball an avalanche rolling
down a hill once it gets started I it's
it's gone out of control now I I don't
know I mean I'm sure we can grains of
sand and kind of slow the thing down
because it's not a literal Avalanche but
it feels like this momentum of
divisiveness between men and women is
has been picking up steam and that's uh
that's concerning of course it's you
know shouldn't change really well I
would think movies like Barbie are sort
of accelerating this right they're
saying men are to blame and I thought
Barbie was making fun of women I've
never seen it so yeah I can't comment I
mean I'm sorry I thought it was more
mocking men it was basically teaching
women don't settle down with a man you
don't want to get married and there was
two scenes where there was a pregnant
Barbie and you know Will Ferrell was the
CEO of Mattel and basically they were
mocking the pregnant Barbie like she was
a discarded model so it was teaching you
know young girls you know don't have
babies and there was a scene at the
start you might have seen it in the
trailer where these uh kids were on the
beach and they had these baby dolls they
were looking after them Barbie came
along suddenly they smashed them so I
thought that was almost a subliminal
message telling kids don't have babies
or you know because it's it's not what
we want in society anymore so I mean I
didn't see it but my My View From the
trailers and the commentary that I have
seen is that if the default presentation
of the Barbies is this happy-go-lucky
world and
then she goes into the real world and
it's not nearly as as bad like I I think
it shows them as like Airhead vapid
stupid
lazy entitled like but I didn't see the
movie so I don't know I got a hot take I
don't think Margot Robbie's that good of
an actor am I I've never heard that she
was good you thought she was good yeah
when I look at her face I just don't see
and Margot come on the show I still love
you but like she's just popular because
she's hot and I maybe maybe I'm wrong
maybe she was great in the movie A lot
of stuff no she was in she's a really
good actress yeah Jared Leto and uh
what's that what's that movie Harley
Quinn right Harley Quinn she was in um
that movie was Wolf of Wall right I did
the worst one of the worst movies I've
ever seen was Birds of Prey was she in
that yes and it was just so I saw a
couple scenes with her and Ryan or not
Ryan Reynolds Ryan Gosling I'm actually
upset you guys made me remember that
movie yeah sorry I mean it's I I hate
objectifying other actors because good
for her doing what she's doing but I
think it's a it's kind of an example of
like where our society is at with
auto-tune and like the hot girl gets the
lead because she's hot and not because
the best actors Amy Schumer originally
for what Harley
well she got a lot of problems right now
would have been an issue I don't know
maybe I didn't know about the problems
when they were doing casting so true
yeah they were it's really funny because
they want to do Amy Schumer because
they're woke and then somebody was like
yeah but there's a limit
like I can't just cast everyone all the
time everywhere yeah I don't know I'm I
someone just said that Margot Robbie
produced the movie is that right yeah it
was yeah yeah
I I don't really care all that much
about the Barbie movie I don't want to
see the Barbie movie what Tim I thought
you were a huge Barbie fan yeah he was
talking about Barbie all the time are
you how how big of a fan of Ryan Gosling
are you one to ten one roll really 100
you love 100
I like Ryan I think he's awesome oh I
think he's one of the best actors on
Earth I I mean I guess it depends on
what you're what does one represent like
not a fan at all and when and 10 is a
big fan not a fan at all but doesn't
mean I don't like the guy I just know
anything about him I don't know whatever
he's a dude it's fine you know he's
doing his thing good for him he was in
Blade Runner he was in place behind the
pines that's how he met his wife Eva
Mendes oh I don't know what that is uh
the notebook and I cried have you seen
it no I have not it'll change you have
you seen it I know what it is but no I
haven't seen it now it's a fantasy
mandatory screen after this
all right I'm going to the bathroom I
love you all let's talk about uh I want
to talk about Sam Harris
let's get a little bit podcast esoteric
we have this clip and there's been a
whole bunch of clips about from Sam
Harris I've been going around president
aren't familiar he's a a very very big
podcaster and um it appears that he has
I don't know if I don't think he lost
his mind
I think that he embodies the grift
perfectly
you've got people who are passionate and
dedicated to what they believe you've
got people like Brett Weinstein who are
very very adamant about their beliefs
and their expertise and then you get Sam
Harris who just says whatever the most
tepid Centrist neoliberal thing is even
if it makes no sense even if you know he
knows he's lying about what he's saying
so he has this clip I'm gonna play this
clip for you guys you know but dial up
the the deadliness of the pathogen you
know give us something like you know
Airborne Ebola that incubates for a
month you know you don't know you have
it and you're what you walk around
spreading it and it's got you know 75
fatality rate and it's mostly killing
kids
no one gets to make that choice anymore
I mean then literally the the cops come
in and vaccinate you and
I I would say that all of us would agree
to that the moment again that you turn
up The lethality on the on the pathogen
you turn up the effectiveness of the
vaccine you turn down the risk of the
vaccine give me a truly safe vaccine
where there's not even one documented
case of vaccine injury right so that
then you just have to be completely
crazy
to be worried about being vaccinated in
that in that kind of environment
um then it's just a no-brainer then then
we just don't tolerate a diversity of
opinion because the stakes are too high
it's it's a full-on emergency bodies of
kids are being stacked up in Parks right
we there's so many of them we don't know
what to do with them we've got these
mobile morgues and we have a vaccine
that actually works and then we've got
RFK Jr saying you know maybe you don't
want you know you maybe you don't want
to get the jab on Rogan's podcast right
that so did you hear what he just said
about RFK Jr he says imagine a scenario
where it's a 75 mortality right the
vaccine is perfect everyone knows it's
perfect and children and children are
dying pot on the street now RFK is
saying don't do it like like no no no no
RFK was talking about now you made up a
fake scenario in your own mind and then
criticized the RFK for saying something
in your own mind dude is losing it he's
completely losing it this was the bodies
in the like he could have children's
bodies in the basement and I would still
vote for him guy right like I I don't
really understand how he made his career
happen when it's based completely
apparently in fiction I wanna I wanna
read the sweet from Dave Smith he said
quote imagine if everything was
completely different then things would
be different imagine if covet had a 100
death rate and the vaccine was perfectly
safe RFK looks pretty stupid now
it's just absolutely remarkable
I'll tell you what I think Sam Harris is
doing
he just wants to stay on the good side
of the machine
he wants to still maintain some kind of
academic contrarian personality type but
he is worried about being the on the
other side of the machine
that's it so what he just had made
literally no sense I missed the best
minute probably but I I also want to
point out too this whole statement let's
just say you have Airborne Ebola
100 percent mortality rate or whatever
30 day incubation like the worst case
scenario
and then RFK Jr comes out and says maybe
you don't want to get the vaccine and
the police are going into people's homes
and forcefully vaccinating them my
response right away is I don't trust the
government
Sam Harris's world is so insane it's
like he lives in this reality where the
government is a big marshmallow man that
wants to hug you like bro the the
government quite literally is a demon is
a gigantic demon with fangs trying to
drink your blood okay there there are
some circumstances where that gigantic
demon does things for us because there
are other gigantic demons trying to
drink our blood you see what I'm saying
and so one day the gigantic government
demon
stops a war from happening like stops an
invasion from coming and showing your
home you go wow thank you so much demon
see this is why we need the demon then
the demon grabs someone cracks him in
half and drinks their blood and throws
their body like the Sam Harris needs to
read a history book because
governments throughout history in almost
every single circumstance are really
really bad there's good things that come
with government small government I'm
talking like small towns and local stuff
tends to work fairly well but
large-scale stuff tends to be very very
demonic and here is a guy so desperate
to stay in the neoliberal space that he
makes this he espouses a sophistry I
wish I'd heard it well I think what's
strange is the mental gymnastics he has
to go through to create a scenario where
the world that he wants is correct where
RFK is you know saying the wrong thing
and doing the wrong thing so he creates
a completely fake scenario
it it seems like the worst talking point
of all time I'm sure I say weird stuff
too on the internet but
it seems indicative of the culture he is
in where I could give you a completely
hypothetical situation that I have made
up and then apply it to a real world
example that actually has nothing to do
with it I love this response from
Tristan Tate he said if ifs and butts
were candies and nuts
that's an excellent excellent response
to Sam Harris I think what happened is
and the reason why I want to talk about
this is like this is the intellectual
dark web guy
this big podcast what was this podcast
called
yeah you remember what it's called it
was Sam Harris something intelligent
something right I don't know and it was
him and he was sit around with Joe Rogan
and Ben Shapiro and Jordan Peterson and
Dave Rubin and they would talk about all
this stuff I was like oh very
fascinating and now he's been going out
saying making sense that was making
sense criticizing Joe Rogan saying he's
captured by his audience I'm like bro
that's quite literally you
Joe Joe Rogan drink just drink Bud Light
Joe Rogan on two occasions cracked up on
the bud lines of the whole thing was
silly despite the massive backlash
against the company it's not audience
capture that's Joe Rogan just being him
and doing what he wants to do this guy
is willing to say whatever nonsense he
can just try and stay in the Limelight
not piss off the neoliberal
establishment
that's the definition of grifting I
suppose
well I'd like to get him in studio at
some point it seems like we have a lot
of uh Familiar of similar friends he was
just with uh with um on Modern wisdom
right yeah but he won't do it he's like
he said in one interview I'd love to
talk with Jordan or or Brett you know
about these things and then he literally
doesn't talk to them
or I don't think you mentioned Brad it
was like Jordan and Joe or something I
don't know bro Weinstein yeah yeah and
then Brett's like he literally won't
talk to us about this and Brett's an
evolutionary biologist so it's just like
he's he's he's it's Plastic Man yeah he
knows he's supposed to say oh no of
course I'd be willing to talk to them
and it's like then do it immediately the
entire time he knows his argument's
flawed he wouldn't win an argument so
that's why he won't if he's allowed to
make up his own facts and everyone
agreed with him 100 then he could win so
I don't understand he can just make up
scenarios all day long and he'll be fine
right that's what we learned from this
interview yeah
I think that's so weird to make this
hypothetical because you don't like RFK
Jr so much that you would say if the
virus was more deadly and also vaccines
were better and also there was a massive
emergency like none of those things
happened point two one time that has
happened where this has been the case he
can't even cite a historical like
precedent it doesn't make any sense to
me it was either playing The Devil's
Advocate to the point where he's playing
dumb I think become the devil
so I think what happened with him is he
has Trump derangement syndrome that is
so weird coming from a guy that's
supposed to be like an intellectual I
don't know
here's what I think happens he sees
Trump losing and he thinks to himself oh
man
if I'm on the side of trump
I'm on the wrong side of History I'm
done I'm gonna come out and say whatever
to say whatever I have to say to be this
Centrist but still in the good side of
the machine personality I get that
forces him to adopt a bunch of positions
that make no sense I get that from Neil
deGrasse Tyson too oh he just said there
was many genders yeah he's a scientist
and he said that yep uh and I'm like I
want to be diplomatic with these guys
but it's just to the point where like
you know if you're gonna be dumb you're
not part of the song You're gonna be
dumb they're evil
either one or the other either you're
they're plaintively stupid or they're
acting maliciously so this is a scary
reality when you see someone like Neil
deGrasse Tyson come out and be like
there are more than two genders you're
like okay how much did they pay you
because like come on dude you can look
up any fifth grade science book and
it'll tell you about the the I'm sorry
more than two Sexes that you look up any
any fifth grade biology book there are
two Sexes oh so did he say there's more
than two genders but no Sexes he said
that we've learned now and then you've
got that guy uh um Colin Wright posted
this the guy who said that there are six
biological sexes
it's like these people are unwell two
plus two equals five their their
worldview is shattered I don't see how
they can build a cohesive Community if
their worldview makes no sense well
you know what I'm thinking about is
religion how do you build a cohesive uh
Community around something that cannot
be proved like if you tell a kid two
plus two equals five but but look here's
two and here's two if you count them
that's one two three four but two plus
two equals five the kid will think okay
I can accept these things even though I
don't I can't prove why or it doesn't
make sense but I will accept that those
are both true and so you could make it
now they're they're logic they're
logical Pathways they're reasoning
breaks because now they can't connect
dots is it do you think that I don't I
don't want to get too deep into religion
but people that just blindly accept have
faith in things that are unprovable that
they're they have like broken logic
Pathways no
do you have to break your logic Pathway
to believe something without proof no
what do you mean well without without
evidential proof so why would you ever
believe it so let's say you stumble
across a spattering of chocolate on your
floor and there is a cake on your
counter that is destroyed something ate
your cake and got the chocolate on the
floor
the first thing we do is we make an
assumption we form a hypothesis okay I'm
going to go ahead and assume that
someone smashed and destroyed the cake
that's apparent by the fact the cake is
smashed and destroyed I'm now going to
assume that it was not a human who did
it because a human would not flip the
cake and the chocolate onto the ground
oh hold on why would you believe
something without proof why would you
operate under this this uh concept
without actually having been able to
prove it the only way to lead yourself
to prove it is if you operate under the
assumption it is potentially true so now
you're sitting here saying it's going to
take me a while to figure out what
happened to this cake but I think it was
an animal that did it okay now we assess
how many animals we have now we have a
cat we have a dog likely not going to be
the cat maybe the cat though the cat may
be like Boop booped it off the counter
maybe the dog jumped up and got it we're
going to choose a hypothesis and then
we're going to pursue it we're going to
operate under an assumption so that we
can try and figure out the truth
now it makes trying to be both the cat
and the dog are covered in chocolate and
you're going to have to operate without
being able to know for sure
my point here is that's logic if you can
look at a cake on the ground and slipped
over and be like okay none of the humans
here did this right it's possible they
did but unlikely they did so I'm not
going to pursue that course of
Investigation that's using logic now if
a child can't understand the concepts
because they've been told two plus two
equals five they look at the cake on the
ground they look at the cake on the
counter they see the smash that smash
the chuck on the floor and they go
a rabbit broke into my house and got my
cake wow they'll be more likely to
believe nonsensical insane things that
you should not be led to believe
you you get what I'm saying oh yeah when
like you pointed out pretty well you say
two and two right that equals four but
then these leftists come out and say two
plus two equals five but if you take the
pencils and lay them out you go one two
three four hey wait a minute that's not
five now if the kid is like nobody but
it is five and there's no fifth pen
there
for the record it's what they're saying
is 2.3 plus 2.3 equals 4.6 when it round
it up yeah and when you round it up
that's five two point three rounded down
is two so technically but generally but
it's not technically right and it's not
even General literally false not math
that's not mathematics either uh so I
don't yeah I don't it's literally false
they're just trying to manipulate people
it's people's ability to formulate
complex ideas sort of like a Sam Harris
argument if things were slightly
different then the outcome would have
been and then yeah but then you have RFK
saying don't take the vaccines like wait
what
that didn't happen in the alternate
reality I've made up for myself I can't
believe what RFK Jr is saying right
based not in reality at all it's like
some angry teenage girl in the shower
thinking about like well you know that
guy was so mean to me I bet he said this
ha he's so dumb it's like and then they
start to believe that it actually
happens like AI generated images like if
I can be like I want exactly this
scenario and now RFK is wrong like it's
so ridiculous I I just don't understand
like what he was trying to accomplish
with this article but I think the big
picture here with what the left is doing
in terms of attacking the ability to
reason and logic is that kids are going
to grow up and they're going to be
unable to understand the world or solve
problems that's the point that's why
they attack math I gotta ask you Ali
because we're about to go to super chats
but I I think maybe your book ties in
this can you tell me really kind of
briefly like what is this book what's it
about and what what happened so gender
Madness is basically talking about all
these issues of kids being confused
online so you know kids taking to tick
tock for validation and how that
algorithm manipulates them it's also
about how schools are you know teachers
are in some cases transitioning kids
without the parents even knowing
um and you know I've got a lot of
research in the book about data which
actually counters the mainstream
narrative and you know mainstream
narrative says there's no D
transitioners it's a very low rate
everybody's happy all these kids live
happily ever after right we know that's
not true it's it's just like we're
talking about you know it's these people
they reject the reality they want you to
reject the logic that's you know cutting
off a girl's breasts is a good thing to
do because it's not but they want us to
believe that that is a good thing so the
book you know covers all these issues it
covers um how people can fall in fall
victim to this kind of gender ideology
and indoctrination you know what are the
solutions out there we've got uh Sweden
has reversed their policy they were the
Pioneers in gender transitions on kids
they have now stopped doing puberty
blockers and hormones on on miners we
have the UK that is also passing similar
laws so you know we see Europe is
slightly ahead of the US and the US is
currently where it's all happening
there's been an explosion in the last
last five years so it's really covering
all of these issues and what we can do
to speak up for these kids you know
speak up for parents so it's um it's out
in a couple of days let's let's uh talk
about a lot more of this in the members
only show we'll get really in depth on
this stuff we can get not so family
friendly but we're gonna go to Super
Chat so if you haven't already smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show if you really do
like it and head over to timcast.com
click join us we're gonna have the
members only uncensored show coming up
in about a half an hour you don't want
to miss it we're going to talk more
about these issues of gender ideology
and there are some uh
some really shocking uh social media
posts from people who have
de-transitioned that are very very sad
that uh we will bring up and I think you
guys need to hear this uh you need to
hear what these these young people are
saying they're they're asking where
their parents were to have helped them
and prevented this and and we'll save it
but we'll read some more Super chats oh
we'll start reading super chats all
right I'm not your buddy guy says I
wanted to get your opinion on the
Michigan election Integrity issues
recently revealed however I gotta say
this song rich men north of Richmond by
Oliver Anthony really hit me deep and
you all need to hear it finally you
should see if you can get Douglas Murray
on I have seen only a little bit about
the Michigan election stuff
and I've asked some friends about it I
don't know enough about it as of right
now and the guy singing that song he
mentioned is giving the one of the
performances of a lifetime you should
find the video and listen to it it's
incredible
Raymond g Stanley juice says Tim don't
you tell me that I'm real that I'm the
only one when you have something to
celebrate you don't call your homeboys
over so you can cuddle up and kiss
so at 6 PM for those that are confused I
uh I saw a tweet from Tristan Tate that
said straight men cuddle and kiss
sometimes in bromances and then I looked
up the story and it had been popping up
on Reddit in a lot of these lgbtq
Community pages and they were like this
is totally legit like straight men hug
kiss and cuddle all the time Bros always
snuggle and I'm like no no they don't
Bros don't snuggle like there's a
picture of two men kissing and it's like
if you're a straight man sometimes you
want to kiss your homie and I'm like
what and apparently Metro published his
story in 2017 where there was a study
done that found that straight men it
said and this I think they're just
trying to lie to kids like they're
trying to trick people into thinking
this is the stuff's normal dudes aren't
doing this like it's just not happening
it said uh when it surveyed most men
said that when they're hanging out with
their with their uh uh with their
friends their male their straight male
friends they will sometimes walk around
naked snuggle with each other and kiss
on the lips no I'm like dude who'd they
survey like those are gay people and
there's no problem with being gay just
say you're gay and I'll say you're a
straight guy and I'm like if they
surveyed a guy who claimed to be
straight but then all said he kissed his
his male friends on the lips he's just
in the closet dude that's not that's all
it's not straight but I thought that was
funny so I did a segment done that's
what Raymond juice Jr is referring to
for Brit says when you start selling
your chickens you should call them cast
brewed chickens it'll match your cast
brew coffee love you guys it's the
chicken City strain we have um we have
to figure out Roberto Roberto Jr's
children and um we believe he has a he
has three two or three sons how are you
gonna decide who gets to be the new king
of the castle over there the new sheriff
in town yeah someone is going to become
the heir to the Roberto lineage and it's
not always uh you know sometimes it's
not always h-based well no I mean look
there's many stories of the the King has
two sons and then one child is chosen
over the other and then the brother is
angry why wasn't I chosen to be the heir
to the throne why is my brother and you
know these other roosters I have to deal
with that Charleston of chicken City
yeah Roberto the third I think maybe an
overthrow of the entire beaks uh lineage
maybe in order I bullish on Luke Luke's
Luke's got the hair man that guy looks
like a dog I say it again and he
actually is he's actually pretty nice
and uh
you know like apparently you can like
he'll crawl into your lap and you can
pet him and stuff and he's super chill
yeah but uh Luke gradkowski tweeted
about it because he's named after Luke
but no no the beaks Dynasty will be
forever we are we are going to have this
great history of you know generations of
the beaks let's hope that it does not
devolve into Civil War it won't so you
know Roberto they're all his kids
like Roberto the one rooster he's got
like 80 children zeused it up dude he's
just well no he's got probably like 50
but then he's got a bunch of grandkids
too like man this dude he he had kids
and he's back the King has returned
and but apparently him and Luke don't
get along and they tried to Spur each
other yeah I think Roberto he's like
battle hardened now spending all he's
always been he's always been pretty
tough I think it's because he's got
Napoleon complex because when they
thought he was a girl and Luke can't be
I can't remember all of them when all
the chains arrived but he can't be the
sheriff because he's not actually a
descendant of Roberto Jr right or is it
well that's obvious you know he's a
usurper but the bigger issue is a domed
head and so if he gets pecked in the
head he'll just die
uh yeah you don't want to make a a week
a weak chicken the king well I'm we
gotta we gotta go look uh Roberto JR's
kids are all still very very young
they're only a few a few weeks I think
and so we need to figure out who's the
boys and who's the girls what if there
aren't any boys
trans chickens well we thought we
thought um
no we thought Roberto was so we bought
we bought I think we got eight baby
chicks that were supposed to be chickens
we don't want rooster we just wanted
chickens we want to just eight and then
uh two of them died and then one of them
started one day went and we were like
what the hell was that and then I'm like
why are that why would a hen Grunt and
they're called Alpha what are the alpha
hens or something like that where if
there's no male a female will become
like
and be basically trans chicken no for
real we'll start acting like a rooster
and then people are just like yo I think
that's just a rooster and then I'm like
what and then the success rate of
successful gendering uh sexing the baby
chicks is like only nine out of ten
ninety percent so we ended up getting a
rooster then I'm like well now we got a
rooster and then he started you know
doing his thing once it got old enough
and then we had eggs and we incubated
them and uh Roberto Jr and uh Maggie and
Bernie were the first three chickens
yeah so Roberto Roberto Jr
two years ago two years ago it was
almost exactly two years ago I remember
it so well in the front yard yeah I
remember when they were in the front
yard in the garden and uh Roberto Jr we
had in the house in our room in a little
cage because he was super tiny and uh
he'd run around and jump up on the bed
and stuff and we had to clean up poop
all the time it was really awful and
disgusting oh yeah he teared up on the
bar downstairs too yeah he'd run around
here yep and then uh but I think because
he was like the first you know of of of
the the breeding there were some issues
he had he had a a messed up foot that
was indicative of some kind of
malnourishment and when when Roberto Jr
was first crowing he would pass out
and there's nothing we could do about
that he would go and just fall hit the
ground and we were like something's
wrong with him but what do you do right
with not much we can't do and so this
explains why he probably had a heart
attack and died dude his crows are the
most unique and I will do it again for
imposterity I love you Junior
like you could hear him really
struggling
[Laughter]
mad love all right waffle sentences
haven't been notified for the show in
three days it must be election season
that's right that's why you guys should
copy Click Share grab the URL post it
wherever you can because YouTube doesn't
want other people to watch the show
that's right
yanet Santana says hi Ali glad you came
through all the madness I follow you on
X Ian moved to Cuba hi Tim hello Cuba
Cuba soy Cubano you're talking about
Cuba
when Mr Burns says he wants to live in
their socialist Paradise
and then Fidel's like you're not talking
about Cuba and then he steals the
trillion dollar bill he's like can I see
it and Mr Burns is like I don't know
he's like okay and then he goes like
okay can I give it back give what back
the trillion dollar bill
classic Simpsons man
what do we got here
okay Psalm says Matt Walsh axed Oliver
Anthony's rich men north of Richmond I
cannot stop listening to him
gotta check that song out I guess
everybody's talking about it's like been
blowing up oh oh I think I saw this the
guy playing guitar in the in like the
super area oh yeah yeah I saw that that
was really good it's an example of like
what makes great music in my opinion
there's no auto-tune it's just a dude I
also love this idea that people are just
like hey this is a really good song I've
got to tell it to you instead of it
being sort of like a big Music Company
that's saying like we're gonna have a
radio release and now everyone's gonna
hear it there's something cool about the
organic nature of this look at this
Barack Tobias Obama says biodynamics
backwards is skim one dib skim's
definition is to remove or embezzle and
dib means money just found that odd one
that proves it yep
dova Ken said fun fact when Oprah
Winfrey bought her property she had the
road connecting Kihei to Kula shut down
it more than doubled the drive time
between the two towns the locals hate
her more than anyone
well why would anyone allow her to do
that
look you know
I just don't know I just don't know
people being like we live in a small
community and a very wealthy person is
shutting our roads down
Shucks it's like bro you got a bad
Police Department you got a bad mayor's
office you got to get these people you
gotta vote them out I don't
graft has a 20 for Ian I don't know what
it was for but you know there you go
there you go 94 made said imagine if
someone could manipulate weather and
cause disasters like this but that'd be
crazy huh well we did end up talking
about and speculating whether or not
China had space lasers well actually I'm
sorry China does have space lasers the
question is can those space lasers start
fires oh and I looked into it from laser
safety facts.com apparently
regular I guess you would call these uh
consumer grade lasers no the redder the
laser the hotter so like Green Lasers
are less hot I think I'm not an expert
and correct me if I'm wrong and that
they don't go very far if it was
infrared lasers you're talking about
lasers you can't see that's not on the
list but it's only like 30 feet that a
red laser came a consumer grid yeah
consumer grid laser so these
high-powered military who knows if
they're even Google search megawatt
laser
I think that's like a psychotically
powerful laser
what does it say
because I think I think kilowatt lasers
are crazy yeah the lasers megawatts are
when Trump creates them Mecca Watts Mega
yeah I'm looking at like five
thousand milliwatt lasers I don't think
that's very much yeah like uh I think I
think the kilowatt lenses are the ones
that start fires I'm not sure like a
megawatt laser would be nuts so you
think if it comes out and someone's like
the cause of this fire was our sin
you're gonna feel more like there's
credibility or you're gonna feel like
it's it's more like there's no way they
would tell us if it was if if the
reality was that China could start fires
with satellites the last thing they want
is for the US to panic there's some
you're gonna get hit with a laser
all right I fly Mile High says Tim I
once had a conversation with a resident
of mine five minutes later I sit down
and see an advertisement for the company
on his shirt I have never heard of the
company before nor looked it up we live
in a simulation
it's procedurally generated that's why
the ads are such
because the AI isn't that sophisticated
we're all playing some kind of video
game oh and I ordered one of those VR
treadmill things
yeah it's like uh it's a bowl you stand
on and strap into and then you have
these special shoes and when you run you
can't actually move and you can like
turn
we got to get all the haptic stuff now
like gloves and vests so you can feel
yourself getting hit and I'll put
together a list okay and then we'll make
a video about it or something yeah it's
gonna be great but I got the thing it's
like you stand it's got this the thing
you strap into and then when you put the
headset on you can play a video game
where you you actually run on the
treadmill can you jump does the harness
hold you yeah
they got super Advanced ones coming out
do they Market it for video games or
like as an exercise video games well
both actually because like you guys do
you guys remember Wii fitness it would
be like you can be on the Wii dude you
want to lose weight play that um what is
it called space pirate trainer yeah
dude that game is so much fun
and uh for those that aren't familiar
you're basically just standing on the
small platform there's a bunch of little
robots that fly around and you have
different types of guns and you're
shooting at them and you can also pull
out a shield and uh like a lightsaber
and whack em it's all around you so you
spin around like 360 doing martial arts
I played that one on the Oculus and then
uh there's one where you're like an
assassin or something you're like
killing people or whatever but I was in
the skate park when I did it and you
have to like punch someone who's coming
close to you and I punch the wall
because you gotta set the boundaries I
didn't do it well so now I've retired
from my VR video game punched the wall
yeah it was like square and then I like
lift up the glasses and I was like it
did hurt but I made me feel like I had a
lot of street cred I felt like a true
video game person you draw the
boundaries and you I think I had just
messed it up because I'm not very good
at it but that's the thing if we if with
this treadmill thing you can you stand
up you can't go anywhere it's much safer
when you're in it you can move around
you've they got to make one where you
can jump yeah and dock too if you can
like well you could definitely Crouch
yeah when you can jump and like go on
your stomach and like fly that's gonna
be I mean I think there are ones that do
that jumping's key also why can you take
wide steps or is it one of the smaller
ones where you've got I have no idea how
big your legs together yeah there's a
new one called the Omni one that has the
single arm that connects to your to a
harness and then it spins around that's
not available yet they're doing this ad
campaign where they like invest in the
company whatever but there's other
treadmills you can
Justin G says to your point Tim I
remember when I saw my first total solar
eclipse total letdown compared to what I
expected thanks to Hollywood and social
media
dude you ever see those photographs
where it's like there's a the Moon is
really really big and there's like a
person standing there and you're like
wow how did they get a picture of the
moon so big they're very very far away
and there's a telephoto lens and they
zoom in and it makes the Moon look big
compared to the backdrop
all of this stuff man so much of life is
just made to look more magical than it
really is
and then you go somewhere and you're
like oh it's cool I guess you know the
colors are always saturated go to
Denmark and you see those photos of like
in Denmark those colorful houses and you
go everything's a bit more dull than
that they brighten the colors come here
the candy is covered in salt it's not
delicious it's rather people sue the
fast food chains that you styrofoam to
make their burgers look bigger I mean
everything's an illusion
what they do is Burgers is when they
make the burger first of all it's like
not even a real Burger but they'll cut
it a triangle in the back and then
spread it out so you can't see the back
of the burger it looks wide yeah it's
such a baggery dude anybody who's ever
seen a commercial for a Big Mac nose you
ain't getting that when you order it how
can they it's that's that's false
advertising but that's Taco Bell come on
Ain't No Way someone's gonna try and
tell me that what I see on the menu is
what they're giving me because it's
always like I love Taco Bell by the way
but it's always smashed you know and
you're just like nah come on there
really was a big class action lawsuit
against uh McDonald's I believe and
there might be one I get to talk about
right now of people who are like showing
the advertisement and saying like this
was not it because there there is a
certain amount of manipulation they're
allowed to do to make the food look
better but they're saying like it's the
reading these are really funny because
it'll be like it's 50 cheesier than
advert or less cheesy than advertise and
like you want to be like who is spending
the time writing this lawsuit but I mean
the consumers aren't happy did you see
that crazy viral video yesterday on
Twitter with that I think it was a man
in a costume he had this kind of weird
neck mask and it was in McDonald's
complaining about the fries did you see
that one yeah I didn't look into it I
think it was fake there's so many people
saying oh it was a man in a mosque or it
was a general woman but they had this
weird mask almost like um Bo select if
you ever saw that it was a comedy show
in the UK um weird but it was all over
the Internet it was actually really
funny but um yeah people have divided
whether it's a real person or just
someone in a mosque you know trying to
be a Karen for attention to go viral
basically so everybody in the chat's
ragging on Taco Bell KP says Taco Bell's
an awesome laxative I actually I
actually don't have any issues when I
eat Taco Bell I was surprised because uh
I I didn't have it for a decade or
whatever and then I decided I was like I
I think I was on like GrubHub or
something and Taco Bell popped up and
I'm like let's I'll have nowhere to talk
about a long time had no problems
whatsoever actually felt decently well
after having it had some recently and
also easily well however however
uh someone said uh let's see simulacra
virus as Taco Bell blows well it's
certainly not food I don't know it
tastes great though and then Diego Zion
says Taco Bell does not look appetizing
ever WTF FairPoint Fair Point and
someone else called it dog food okay I I
accept it but uh the thing is Taco Bell
pioneered staying open super late and
even now in this area it's open the
latest so if you want food after I don't
know your late night podcasting thing
you know you go to Taco Bell that's what
you guys have you seen out there for a
long time and as a skateboarder
tradition after we finish skating we'd
get Taco Bell and then we'd get Baja
Blast but have you ever have you seen
the meme where it's like Taco Bell it's
four in the morning and there's like a
Maserati and then like a 1992 Chevy or
an equalizer the great equalizer
everybody's just trying to live Mass yo
we went to Taco Bell last weekend
and it was like I don't know what time
it was it was like 10 or something and
that's exactly what we saw there were
like two sports cars in the front
looking really nice and then regular
cars behind and I was like man people
really just want to live Moss yeah they
do and Taco Bell is interesting because
they have their like number one it uh
popular among vegans and vegetarians
because they have more options but but
also they have their Cantinas where
they're like different restaurants where
they can serve alcohol there's someone
like major city so as a brand I actually
think they're really interesting uh they
can't make you eat there if you don't
want to I've seen how they make the food
because there's an instagramer who like
his account is like Taco Bell prep it's
disgusting oh why it's so nasty like the
beans are a bag of powder that they pour
into like a vet and then it like it's
just like a gel that reconstitutes when
they grab the beef I'm just like I do
not want to eat any of that but then we
end up at Taco Bell but the cheese is
fine is it yeah the cheese is fine I
used to love it in the 90s I don't I
don't I don't like wheat tortillas yeah
I'm away from that now corn tortillas
and even then I try to avoid that you
know if I go we go to uh there's a
really really great Mexican restaurant
called me degoyato which apparently
means like slitting a man's throat in
Spanish yeah apparently but uh it's
amazing and it's out here in West
Virginia so I always get fajitas and I
just say no tortillas and then it's just
yeah it's like as healthy as healthy can
be it's chicken peppers and onions you
know how you gonna go wrong with that I
call it real Taco Bell
all right a green Clover says the lasers
from China could be from lidar mapping
bunkers and ideal targets for a first
strike
yep but China said it was nothing they
said it was nothing to worry about right
so we should trust them they're just
looking for pollution centers they said
that about covert didn't they when it
first came out they said oh it's nothing
to worry about it's fine we're
containing it and look what happened so
we can't trust their word Christopher
Mar says Tim you should make a rise with
Roberto Jr zombie version with a foot
coming out of the ground or Roberto Jr
coffee's strong enough to Wake the Dead
also rip Roberto Jr how about I love
that comment because it's like let's
make fun of the fact that he died also
rip how about for Halloween we make a
blend called re-rise with Roberto Jr
he's back we'll do only a couple hundred
of them
and it'll be like a premium roast
you know limited edition Halloween blend
I'll drink it I'll be funny that'd be
cool because I mean most brands roll out
the pumpkin spice in the fall and you
guys would have a Halloween Brent blend
re-rise with Roberto Jr and it'll be a
zombie foot coming out of a we're giving
him a viking funeral this Sunday I think
oh I'm gonna miss it so we we have uh we
have a pond and so we're going to make a
little boat put Reeds on it Place him on
it we're gonna tie a rock to a string
tie the end to the little boat and throw
it into the middle of the pond so that
it anchors it and then we're going to
you know throw a little fire on it oh
yeah give him a little Viking funeral
yeah poor little guy he didn't have a
good heart we don't think great but
they're chickens I mean in any other
world you probably would have been food
he would have been killed and eaten when
he started hurting the hens well what
they do is they they call it giving them
to Nature because you don't want boys so
when you're when you're naturally
hatching the eggs when you get boys you
just take them out of the coop and place
them on the ground and that's it you
walk away and little dude just isn't
there tomorrow
well that's giving them back to Nature
we've got uh like 10 roosters at
cocktown over at freedomastan and I'm
like why do we have these roosters let's
eat them their food one of like they've
been fighting because they don't really
they're not they don't really like the
idea of we're just killing each other is
not really true only if there's girls
around
so they're mostly fine but they're not
living well and I'm like let's just put
them in a pressure cooker man and then
have some rooster stew
do you need to get them checked for
parasites or anything
uh I no I I we've raised them and I
don't think we have to worry about that
they're fed Farm like organic good stuff
but um Chris doesn't want to eat them so
I was like okay then let's just open the
door
let them go do their thing you know what
I I really would love this idea if we
had like 50 roosters I Envision this fox
like sneaking up onto the property and
like hearing the rooster crow and
thinking I'm gonna get me some food and
then he like sees one rooster sitting
there looking around you know bobbing
its head and the fox is like oh yeah and
the fox creeps Fox creeps up and then it
jumps for the rooster and then all of a
sudden like there's 300 roosters with
glowing eyes looking at the fox and the
fox like no what is this and then the
roosters eat the fox instead that'd be
awesome yeah that'd be so cool Rooster's
being like that'd be good commercial for
stand your grounds
[Laughter]
yeah
in memory of Roberto Jr
all right we'll grab a couple more Super
chants what do we got over here
Eric Allman says Tim multiple kind of
fires not started by satellite lasers
and Tim Hawaii fires could have been
started by satellite laser
so what I said was the most likely
scenario in Hawaii is that someone's cow
kicked over a lantern alright the most
likely scenario in Canada was there was
actually a map showing a bunch of
lightning strikes now could there have
been you know uh attacks by yeah for
sure I'm not I'm not like I'm literally
calling it a conspiracy theory and just
talking about weapons capabilities but I
gotta I gotta be honest
I'm willing to bet somebody's cow kicked
over a lantern
reference right yes I don't know I don't
know if that was a unique to Chicago
thing and I was like saying we all
observe Chicago culture in this house
what do we do what's her name we ordered
Portillo's today oh cool yeah maybe we
should have hot dogs do you know the I
went to a Portillo's for the first time
over the summer and it was very cool you
it you want to talk about fast food okay
Portillo's is the best ever
no question my only question is do they
have green dye in the um relish because
it's very green no no no no I'm pretty
sure they don't there's a lot yeah
relish it's just good it's really good I
think we should have a good question
though because I I thought that too yeah
I think we should have a board game or
card game where we like create
conspiracy theories because you know you
were just speculating about the lasers
we should be allowed to talk freely yeah
Like Cards Against Humanity but instead
of I don't know whatever they're doing
you make conspiracies like false false
Flags oh that is a good idea for a game
like kind of like Cards Against Humanity
but you have different conspiracy
theories and so everyone gets dealt
cards and then so you have like a result
and a conspiracy it's like the tin foil
that's a good idea and then people will
like there we have we have there
there'll be three sets of cards there
will be like conspiracy and result and
then there will be like
um
the like the the the Scandal or
something right so someone draws a card
and it says like wildfires were started
in Canada and then everyone has to
choose two cards
you know stuff like that well obviously
that isn't it one of them will be like
cow kicks over Lantern and then the
other one is you know causing a massive
explosion which destroys three small
towns and then you like play it down and
then people will vote on who they think
is the funniest and then just like that
you know you win yeah that'd be fun all
right you've heard it wants to make it
also we should probably open source the
video game love the idea I think we
should create a Discord room and we'll
we'll send the we'll put the code out in
the disc in the video game Discord
server people can just make the game
that's a good idea it's game maker I
think yeah yeah
that would be good
Matthew draga says my family just bought
a restaurant in Lahaina that used to be
a chart house we were renovating it and
now it's gone I'm not looking for
sympathy lots of people lost their homes
pray for Maui I'm sorry to hear it
speaking of Kellen uh sent us a map on
Twitter you could pull up if you want
from Steve lookner it's at lookner
l-o-o-k-n-e-r and it's a map of all the
houses that were destroyed in the fires
all this red stuff I don't know if it's
accurate but it is devastating to look
at apparently there's a lot of houses
and it's a lot of coastal stuff I guess
is that they're all on the coast and
then there's Mountain they can't really
get up in the in the mountain yeah I
think so I'm not your Junior Raymond
that's a very good name says dandelions
have medicinal properties in the sap all
parts are edible leaves taste a bit like
kale boil the roots for hours to make
soup nectar makes a delicious jelly bees
love them dandelions are the chicken of
the Plant World I grew up with
dandelions being garbage and we're like
trying to get rid of them and then I
learned out here that they were actually
brought here intentionally because they
were medicinal and you can look up
Appalachian dandelion recipes they
batter and deep fry them and apparently
they taste like mushrooms so actually
Ian started it when he when he mentioned
dandelion tea and then we were at I
think Mom's Organic and we bought some
we bought a couple different kinds and
it was the best tea I've ever had
I was like I can't remember what it was
I think it was like vanilla or something
and I was like this is amazing and those
circular ones yeah yeah those are so
great some people use is it dandelion
tea or you know some combination fruits
as a replacement for coffee they say
don't drink the coffee drink this it'll
give you the energy boost a very nice
Tradesman mountain man when I moved to
West Virginia told me that wow yep
all right let's grab some more what do
you have this Nina a says rest easy
Roberto Roberto Jr Roberto his dad is
still around
all right
purple says give Tim his Viking funeral
I fully intend to have a viking funeral
when I die and it has been declared as
so so this is in the public record on
the pond uh no wherever it'll be like in
Norway with legit Vikings too that'd be
cool that'd be awesome but I I I I
thought about this when I was younger
it's like why would you want to be
embalmed and put in a box and Berry that
sounds horrifying nah put me on a boat
kicking out to sea and set me on fire
what about shot being shot into space I
don't know that's weird all right
everybody if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends head over to
timcast.com click join us become a
member because we're going to talk about
some spicy not so family-friendly issues
but uh you should join the conversation
we've got a lot of gender ideology
issues to discuss and that'll be up in a
few minutes you can follow the show at
timcastirl you can follow me personally
at timcast Ollie do you want to shout
anything out
um yeah so anyone that's interested in
gender ideology and trying to tackle
this um please pre-order my book gender
Madness right now and let's you know
solve this issue together let's talk
about this issue have a conversation
let's do what's best for kids do you
have a website in particular you'd like
people to buy it from
um so it's on Amazon Barnes and Nobles
Walmart and you know for all of this
gender ideology exposing I do a lot of
my Twitter so at Ollie London TV so
people can find it on there and you know
I'm always sharing all of these woke
stories and new legislation that's being
introduced in different states because I
think it's very important that people go
and testify against these bills that are
trying to force uh legislation for
gender affirming care and oftentimes
Democrats try to push it through without
people and residents even realizing so
you know I highlighted a lot of that on
my Twitter and you know I think it's
important to share that
that's awesome well it's been awesome to
have you here thank you I'm Hannah
Claire brimlow I'm a writer for
timcast.com you should follow at timcast
news on Twitter on Instagram definitely
check out the story that Chris Bertman
published today about Florida and what's
going on there it's really interesting
who's talking about it in the office if
you want to follow me personally you can
follow me on Instagram at Hannah
clairedappy or on Twitter at HC bromo
thank you so much thanks for all your
work man really cool I followed you on
Twitter TV big pleasure um great so
catch you later man gender Madness
thanks for coming dude pick it up on
Amazon or wherever books are sold I'm
Ian Crossing and I will see you later
yep pleasure to see you ollie as always
uh I am surge.com I'm ready for this
after show let's just get to it we will
see you all over at timcast.com thanks
for hanging out